Herzlich willkommen zu Alternativlos, die Folge 10.
Mit Fefe und Frank. Und wir haben wieder eine Sondersendung geplant für euch aufgrund der Zuschauerfragen, nämlich Wikileaks.
Ja, wir dachten uns, wir müssen mal über dieses Thema Wikileaks reden. Zwar reden gerade einfach alle über Wikileaks, lässt sich wohl nicht vermeiden, aber ich dachte uns vielleicht können wir da doch ein paar Perspektiven beisteuern, die ihr so in der normalen Mainstream-Presse oder den Blogs und dergleichen Dingen nicht findet. Und da wollen wir heute mal ein bisschen ausführlicher drauf eingehen.
Wir hatten ja eigentlich sowieso vor, über Wikileaks zu reden, wir wollten aber noch warten, bis OpenLeaks online ist, da kommen wir nachher noch zu. Aber jetzt hat sich das in der Presse doch hinreichend überschlagen, dass wir das vorgezogen haben. Wir machen aber noch zusätzlich eine Sendung zu OpenLeaks.
Mal sehen wir zum Ende denn nochmal. Ja, zuerst mal natürlich immer die Hausmeister-Themen abhaken, nicht wahr?
Genau. Herzlichen Dank fürs Flattern, es kommt immer noch rein, das Geld. Und wir haben überlegt, was wir damit sinnvoll tun können, jetzt wo unsere Ausrüstung eigentlich perfekt ist. Und wir haben uns gedacht, wir kaufen mal ein paar gute Bücher damit.
Genau, wir wollen eigentlich jetzt so die Flatterkohle für Bücher im Wesentlichen auf den Kopf hauen und für Subscriptions zu Online-Informationsdiensten, die halt sonst einen heiligen Geld kosten, aber wo möglicherweise interessante Informationen drinstehen. Gerade so aus unserer Lieblingsecke, so der schattigen Geheimdienstwelt. Es gibt da halt so eine Reihe von solchen Informationsdiensten, die dann immer so was, irgendwie so 3, 4, 5, 600 Euro mehr kosten. Und wo dann jeweils über das Land, aus dem dieser Dienst kommt, fast nichts zu finden ist. Aber die lässt es natürlich fröhlich über alle anderen. Am letzten haben wir natürlich Spaß. Deswegen werden wir das wohl so machen. Wir werden natürlich dann auch erzählen, was wir dann so da subscribieren und warum wir es wieder an subscribieren, wenn es scheiße ist. Ja, diese Folge haben wir noch kein Buch.
Das gibt es ja auch kein Buch. Das ist ja ein reines Online-Thema. Wir sind allerdings angesprochen worden gerade von einem freien Radio aus Berlin, die unsere Podcasts ausstrahlen wollen. Weil das eigentlich eine Sache ist, die wir unterstützenswert finden, haben wir uns gedacht, das sprechen wir gleich mal hier an. Grundsätzlich haben wir da kein Problem mit. Es muss allerdings vorher eine Abstimmung geben, damit wir da vielleicht auch drauf hinweisen können. Und das muss ungekürzt ausgestrahlt werden.
Genau, ungekürzt und ohne Änderung des Labels. Es muss halt weiter Alternativlos heißen. Wenn ihr damit einverstanden seid und ein freies Radio oder auch ein anderes Radio betreibt und das so machen wollt, dann schickt uns einfach eine Mail, dann können wir das abstimmen können. Wir haben damit kein Problem, wir freuen uns da eigentlich sehr drüber. So, dann zum Thema. Wikileaks, was tut denn dieses Wikileaks eigentlich?
Ja, Wikileaks ist eine Webseite, die zwar Wiki heißt, aber eigentlich mit anderen Wikis nicht viel zu tun hat. So an der Wikipedia oder was man so kennt.
Vorne hängt immer noch so ein hässliches Media-Wiki davor.
Nur zum Rendern allerdings, das ist nicht für Eingaben.
Ich glaube, die haben sich dann schon mehrere Male drüber geärgert, dass sich damit diese Media-Wiki so derbessen in den Fuß geschrissen haben.
Sie haben sich was eingetreten.
Also ich meine, bemerkswert, das ist ja dieselbe Technologie, mit der auch die Wikipedia großflächig versagt.
Ja, und auch die haben ja echt Schmerzen damit. Na ja, also Wikileaks jedenfalls, die Idee ist, das ist eine Webseite und da kann man hingehen, wenn man geheime Daten hat. Informationen, von denen man glaubt, dass die Weltöffentlichkeit sie erfahren muss. Dann kann man zu Wikileaks gehen und die dahinschicken, beziehungsweise konnte man. Im Moment ist das Submission-Interface nicht verfügbar. Aber also die Idee ist, jedenfalls man geht dahin und gibt ihnen seine Daten, die man da liegen möchte. Und dann tun die das online und geben das der Presse und sorgen auch so ein bisschen dafür, dass es publiziert wird, ohne dass das zurückverfolgbar ist zu der Quelle.
Genau, also eigentlich ist das ganze Ding ein Anonymisierungsdienst für Dokumente. Also eine Möglichkeit, Dokumente zu publizieren oder auch Datenbanken oder Abzüge ganzer Festplatten oder was auch immer, so zu publizieren, dass man sich als Quelle, also derjenige, der über diese Daten gestolpert ist, keine sorgen machen muss, zurückverfolgt zu werden. Dass ja dann irgendwas in den Daten selber ist, zum Beispiel so, dass es halt schwierig ist, geheimzuhalten. Wenn nur zwei Personen Zugriff auf diese Daten haben.
Und der andere weiß ja was nicht.
Der andere weiß ja was nicht, denn es ist ein bisschen schwierig, das noch zu leugnen. Insofern kann natürlich so eine Anonymisierungsplattform für Dokumente einem nicht komplettes Denken abnehmen, wenn man auf solche Dokumente stößt und die leaken möchte. Aber sie kann natürlich viele Sachen einfacher machen, insbesondere halt auch den Kontakt mit der Presse. Das ist ja eine der großen Schwierigkeiten bei Presse, ist ja eben die häufig nicht gänzlich genaue Trennung der Interessen von Journalisten und staatlichen Stellen oder Konzernen und dergleichen Dingen mehr. Und Presse ist natürlich auch immer abhängig von den Leuten, die bei ihnen Anzeigen schalten. Deswegen bestimmte Sachen da einfach schlicht nicht publiziert werden. Also es hat schon doch auch gerade in der deutschen Pressegeschichte gibt es viele Geschichten, die wurden einfach schlicht nie publiziert, obwohl es da stabilerweise Dokumente zugabe und vollkommen klar war, dass es keine Frage der Glaubwürdigkeit ist.
Aber es gibt auch so eine eingebildete Aufmerksamkeitsökonomie, dass die Presse ja auch so viele Meldungen über den Ticker kommen hat, aus denen sie halt immer wählen, welche sie da zu Agenda machen und in ihr Blatt hieven. Und mit denen müssen dann Leaks eben konkurrieren. Und da kommt es eben auch durchaus mal vor, dass wenn es Leaksame in Kenia spielt, dass die deutsche Presse überhaupt kein Interesse daran hat, da irgendwas zu bringen, weil sie glaubt, die Bevölkerung interessiert es einfach mal nicht. Und insofern hat sich auch die Herangehensweise von Wikileaks mit der Zeit geändert. Weil eben aufgefallen ist, dass die Presse die Leaks nur sehr zögerlich angenommen hat.
Aber das wollten wir gleich nochmal ein bisschen ausführlicher machen. Genau, diese Strategie. Ich denke, wir sollten noch so ein bisschen über genau dieses Thema reden. Warum wollen denn Leute Sachen publizieren? Also welche Intention steckt dahinter? Wenn zum Beispiel jemand Dokumente, wie jetzt gerade diese Sammlung von US State Department, also des amerikanischen Außenministeriums, Nachrichten findet. Was ist die Motivation von Leuten, sie publizieren zu wollen? Was man immer häufiger sieht, sind eben Leute, die nicht mehr aushalten, was da eigentlich passiert. Also die einfach die Schweinereien, die da passieren, die da mitwisser werden, einfach mit ihrem Gewissen nicht mehr vereinbaren können. Die einfach sagen, muss irgendwie ein Ende haben. Und am besten hat es halt möglicherweise ein Ende, wenn da mehr Leute von wissen.
Lustigerweise sind die Gesetze ja sehr klar an der Stelle in Sachen Komplizenschaft. In den USA ist zum Beispiel so, dass derjenige, der das Fluchtauto beim Mord fährt, genauso für den Mord bestraft wird, auch mit gleicher Härte, wie der eigentliche Mörder. Das heißt, wenn man diese Art von Gesetz um sich herum hat, wenn man aufwächst und dann im State Department sitzt und sieht, dass die da einfach hinnehmen, dass Zehntausende von Menschen zu Tode kommen und wenn man einfach die Gesetze des Landes darauf anwendet und dann muss man einfach auch selber zu dem Schluss kommen, man ist da Komplize. Und das erzeugt einen Druck, den also viele Leute halten den nicht aus. Wir hatten hier den Markus Komper hier zu einer Geheimdienstsendung, die haben ja ähnliche Probleme und der meinte ja sehr, sehr poentiert, dass eine der häufigsten Krankheiten bei Geheimdienstlern ist Leberzirrhose, weil das kann man sich natürlich durch Besaufen losreisen, dieses Problem, dass man sie einfach betäubt mit irgendwelchen Drogen oder Alkohol. Oder manche Leute haben halt sowas wie einen Gewissen noch und die haben dann das Bedürfnis, das an die Öffentlichkeit zu geben. Das ist ja schwieriger als man denkt übrigens, da kommen wir auch gleich noch zu.
Also genau diese Sachen mit dem Gewissen ist ja schon so, dass auch zu Zeiten des Kreitenkrieges waren auf beiden Seiten die Anzahl der Spione, die für die Gegenseite gearbeitet haben, aus Gewissensgründen, also die halt eben nicht da Geld für haben wollten oder sonst irgendwas, oder das Geld halt maximal billig in Kauf genommen haben, war erstaunlich hoch. Also wo man es hätte nicht denken sollen, aber der Interesse war...
Auch der Hauptspion der Russen war so. Und auch bei den Amis war es wahrscheinlich so, ne?
Also da gibt es jetzt keine Zahlen, aber... Also ich war jedenfalls immerhin doch noch eine gewisse Zahl. Also klar gibt es immer noch und gab es damals natürlich auch welche, die halt einfach entweder aus dem Osten nur raus wollten und irgendwie sich dann zumindest ein Startkapital geschaffen wollten. Und andersherum gab es halt welche, die ja Probleme hatten mit dem, was im Westen passierte. Also wie zum Beispiel die beiden NSA-Spioner, die dann da in Moskow gelandet waren, die halt einfach schwul waren und nicht damit klarkommen, dass halt die Kultur da halt in dem Teil des Militärs auch so antischwulen war. Und klar, solche Sachen gibt es halt auch immer, aber es gibt trotzdem immer noch eine ganze Menge Leute, die halt einfach trotzdem immer noch, trotz allem immer noch ein Gewissen haben. Und für so eine Leute eine Möglichkeit zu schaffen, mit ihrem Gewissen was anzufangen, also zu Sachen, die halt einfach im Geheimen passieren und die Sauereien sind, die rauskommen sollten, zu veröffentlichen. Dafür sollte halt eigentlich nach der gängigen Definition unseres Systems ja die Presse da sein, dass sie halt einfach dann Sachen aufdeckt und Ungerechtigkeiten anprangert und möglicherweise dazu führt, dass halt Sachen korrigiert werden. Aber wenn man sich so die Realität anguckt, sind halt Whistleblower, also Leute, die die Trillerpfeife blasen, um auf eine Ungerechtigkeit hinzuweisen. Da hat der englische Begriff Whistleblower, Pfeifenpuster, ist doch recht gering. Also da gibt es dann halt immer einen Informantenschutz, den halt die Presse ist, also durchaus ja ein relativ starkes Recht. Na ja, also in der Praxis ist halt eben genau das Problem. Der Informantenschutz ist ja doch irgendwie ziemlich ausgehöhlt. Es gab mal wieder eine Stärkung mit dem Zizore-Urteil, dass eben nicht allein der Verdacht des Vorhandenseins von geheimen Unterlagen dazu dienen kann, da eine Hausdiskussion durchzuführen, um den Informanten festzustellen, was sehr effektiv das war, was da der BKA gemacht hatte. Aber in der Praxis ist es schon so, dass gerade zum Beispiel mit der Vorratsdatenspeicherung halt die Rechte der Journalisten, mit ihren Informanten zu kommunizieren, relativ eingeschränkt sind. Was zum Beispiel, ich muss mich da jedes Mal wieder darüber aufregen, dass der Spiegel mittlerweile offensichtlich auf Druck seiner Chefredaktion pro Vorratsdatenspeicherung ist. Das ist einfach so ein dermaßener Skandal irgendwie in dieser Presselandschaft. Da können sie irgendwie noch so viele Wikileaks publizieren. Das können sie nicht wieder gut machen, wenn sie davon nicht runterkommen.
Wir können ja kurz erklären, woran es liegt. Die Chefredaktion ist nämlich die ursprüngliche Geheimdienstabteilung.
Genau, also einer der Chefredakteure, der jetzt da beim Spiegel unterwegs, der Maskelo, war halt vorher der Redakteur für Geheimdienstangelegenheiten und der hat offensichtlich dann einmal zu viel Mittag mit den Jungs gegessen. Und sich zu sehr deren Weltbild angenähert. Also wie man als Presse-Medium vertreten kann, dass irgendwie seine eigene Möglichkeit mit Informanten im Vertrauen und Kontakt zu treten abgeschafft wird, das erschließt sich mir überhaupt nicht. Da fehlt mir auch wirklich jeglicher rationaler Erklärungsansatz.
Also Whistleblower Schutz geht in den USA noch einen Schritt weiter als bei uns. Bei uns ist es ja so, dass die Presse nicht gezwungen werden kann, Informanten rauszudrücken. Aber was ist denn, wenn jetzt der Informant bekannt wird, dann hat man bei uns verkackt. Dann gibt es keinen Schutz, der dich davor schützt, dass die Firma dich rausschmeißt oder die Regierungsagentur oder wo auch immer man gearbeitet hat, wenn man da was geleakt hat. In den USA gibt es einen Whistleblower Schutz, der, also es gab zum Beispiel einen Fall von einer Frau, die hat in einer Mine gearbeitet, wenn ich mich recht in den Sinne, und hat eben rausgefunden, dass die da Giftmüll irgendwie verklappt haben oder irgendwie so. Also Fälle wie der, da darf dann die Mine den Leaker nicht rausschmeißen. Natürlich gibt es da Wege und Mittel darum. Also zum Beispiel...
Ob man denn da noch arbeiten will, ist auch die andere Frage.
Ja, na klar, aber also jedenfalls grundsätzlich heißt es so, dass dir kein Nachteil daraus erwachsen darf, dass du auf Missstände hinweist. Das ist ja an sich ein sehr heeres Ziel, was selbst wenn es in der Praxis nicht so funktioniert, ich doch trotzdem gerne im Gesetz hätte. In den USA ist es jetzt so, dass natürlich viele Leakfälle sich um die Regierung handeln und dass dann die Methode, den doch rauszueckelen ist, dass man ihm einfach die Clearance streicht, also den Zugang zu Geheiminformationen herabstuft. Und dann hat er zwar auf dem Papier seinen Job noch, aber darf die ganzen Akten nicht sehen, die er braucht, um den Job zu erfüllen und sitzt dann da quasi rum und darf nichts tun. Und das ist natürlich auch scheiße. Also der Brüsselblaue Schutz ist auch in Amerika eher auf dem Papier als tatsächlich in der Praxis, aber es gibt ihn zumindest und das würde ich mir hier auch wünschen.
Ja, es gab doch so einen Ansatz dazu, ein Informantenschutzgesetz oder sowas. Ich weiß nicht genau, was da passiert ist. Wir haben auf dem Kongress eine Veranstaltung von einem Verein, der sich eben um Whistleblower kümmert und da wird es auch eine Ausstellung zu geben auf dem Kongress, wo so ein bisschen Whistleblower-Schicksale vorgestellt werden, dass man mal sehen kann, was mit den Leuten passiert ist, die benamst wurden, also deren Namen bekannt wurden. Und am Ende ist es aber schon so, dass wenn ich halt auf so etwas sitzen würde, also mir solche Sachen bekannt würden, dann würde ich mich da auf jeden Fall darum kümmern, dass mein Name damit nicht in Verbindung gebracht wird. Aus Selbstschutz? Einfach damit ich nicht den Rest meines Lebens damit verbringe, mich mit diesen Folgen auseinandersetzen zu müssen. Und wenn man sich so die Geschichte anguckt, dann ist es in der Regel so, dass Leute, deren Identität geschützt wurde, also die halt eben nicht offengelegt wurden, dass die in der Regel kein Problem hatten. Also in aller seltensten Fällen sind die gekriegt worden. Also gab es natürlich so Fälle wie zum Beispiel gerade bei Google, wo so ein Google-Employee geleakt hatte, dass irgendwie Google durch die Bank alle Gehälter um 10% erhöht, damit die Leute nicht abhauen.
Das ist natürlich die falsche Firma, um so was zu tun. Die machen Data-Mining.
Genau. Meine Vermutung war schlicht, dass die, dass er am Ende einer der Journalisten einen Gmail-Account hatte, bei dem es gelandet ist oder seine E-Mail auf den Gmail-Account gefordert hat. Man sollte schon wissen, was man so tut. Das ist sicherlich eines der Dinge, die momentan so ein bisschen fehlen. Das ist so ein Proper Leaking-Menü. Also wie man einfach rundlich leakt.
Das ist ja eigentlich auch genau die Sache, die Wikileaks übernehmen wollte. Das ist einfach eine Webseite, da gehst du hin und lädst es hoch. Und die haben dann alle möglichen technischen Tricks angewendet, um das geheim zu halten. Die können wir jetzt hier nicht groß erklären, aber im Wesentlichen haben die verschiedene Server in verschiedenen Juris-Sektionen gehabt und haben den Webserver nochmal durch Proxys getrennt von dem User, sodass bei dem Leaking-Interface, wo tatsächlich die Software sitzt, die eben die geleakten Dokumente entgegennimmt, da ist halt nicht mehr zu sehen, von welcher IP eigentlich das Dokument kam. Das heißt, selbst innerhalb der Site muss man also die gesamte Site übernehmen, quasi um da selbst intern als Mitarbeiter von Wikileaks irgendwelche Sachen rauszusehen. Das heißt, selbst die können gar nicht wissen, ob dieser Bradley Manning jetzt eigentlich der Leaker ist oder nicht, in dem Fall von den Memos. Das wird jetzt natürlich in der Presse immer so dargestellt. Aber wichtig an der Stelle ist eben zu sagen, ist das nicht durch Wikileaks bekannt geworden. Die hätten es auch gar nicht sagen können, dass er das ist, sondern der hat sich halt blöd angestellt und hat es selber erzählt. Und da hilft natürlich die beste Technik nichts.
Also das ist halt auch der, denke ich mal, der zweitwichtigste Hinweis für Leaker, die halt im verborgenen bleiben wollen auf Selbstschutz.
Klapp halten.
Genau, ganz wichtig. Klapp halten. Mit niemandem drüber reden. So mit niemandem, der irgendwie, also vielleicht kann man es ja noch der Freundin oder seinem Freund erzählen, aber vielmehr dann halt eben auch nicht.
Wir können vielleicht einen Filmtipp an der Stelle geben. Wag the dog.
Richtig, ja, Wag the dog sollten wir tatsächlich mal wieder erwähnen. Einer der wirklich wichtigen Filme, sowohl zum Thema politische Propaganda als auch zum Thema Leaks und dergleichen Dinge mehr.
Und zum Thema Klappe halten.
Zum Thema Klappe halten. Richtig, genau. Ja, na gut. Also jetzt haben wir ein bisschen erklärt, was Wikileaks tat. Momentan, wie gesagt, ist das Submission-Interface nicht online, weil offenbar die ganze Infrastruktur so ein bisschen desolat zu sein scheint.
Ja, da sind auch Kam-Leute weggelaufen. Also es gab da so eine Art Krieg innerhalb Wikileaks.
Ja, ein Split, würde man halt sagen.
Ein Split, genau, ein Netz-Split.
Ja, und wie gesagt, der zweite Teil wird sich jetzt offensichtlich unter den Namen OpenLeaks konstituieren. Und da werden wir dann nochmal eine extra Sendung zu machen, um dann nochmal, da geben wir nochmal ein bisschen mehr auf die Details ein, also was die Herausforderungen daran sind, so eine Leaking-Plattform technisch ordentlich zu gestalten und zu betreiben und sich hier zu stellen, dass die Identität des Leakers halt nicht bekannt werden kann. Da gibt es dann sicherlich auch noch so Themen wie dafür zu sorgen, dass Dokumente ordentlich optimisiert werden, also dass man in der Lage ist, zum Beispiel Markierungen von Dokumenten zu entfernen, die möglicherweise Hinweise darauf geben, über welchen Weg es auf die Plattform gelangt ist.
Also da gab es auch schon mal einen Vortrag von den Wikileaks-Leuten auf dem CCC-Kongress, wo sie das beschrieben haben und den können wir vielleicht auch verlinken. Der ist durchaus empfehlenswert an der Stelle.
Aber vielleicht soll man noch mal so einen Schritt zurücktreten und diese Frage, warum ist es denn gut, dass solche Geheimnisse an die Öffentlichkeit kommen?
Und welche Geheimnisse sollen überhaupt an die Öffentlichkeit kommen?
Genau, welche Geheimnisse sollten eigentlich in die Öffentlichkeit kommen.
Gibt es da so etwas wie eine Ethik, die man da anwenden kann?
Eine Leaking-Ethik?
Nein, aber es gibt eine Hacker-Ethik. Und das finde ich durchaus wichtig zu sagen, dass diese Fragestellungen ethischer Natur sich den Hackern schon ewig stellen. Weil wir haben vielleicht nicht Zugriff auf die Daten gehabt, wir Hacker, aber wir hatten Zugriff auf irgendwelche Rechnersysteme von anderen Leuten, als das noch nicht verboten war.
Damals, als das noch nicht verboten war.
Also jetzt mal rein hypothetisch und historisch gesprochen. Und natürlich haben wir genau dieselben ethischen Fragen gehabt. So können wir uns da jetzt einloggen. Und wenn wir uns da einloggen, was können wir dann da tun? Und wir haben als Hacker-Vereinigung, also jetzt der CTC natürlich, aber auch insgesamt gibt es eine Hacker-Ethik. Und da stehen so Sachen drin, wie, dass man öffentliche Daten nutzen soll und private Daten schützen. Und in fremden Daten soll man nicht rummölen.
Interessanterweise sind genau diese beiden Hinzufügungen.
Die sind die vom CTC?
Die sind von VAU. Die hat VAU da reingeschrieben. Also die ursprüngliche Hacker-Ethik hat der Steven Nevey, mal aufgeschrieben, ein Journalist, der die Hacker-Szene sehr intensiv beobachtet hat und der sozusagen die ersten Absätze geschrieben hat. Und die beiden letzten Ergänzungen sind eben entstanden nach dem Problemfall, dass ein paar Leute aus dem CCC-Umfeld sich für einen Geheimdienst verdingt hatten, um Rechner aufzumachen und da Daten auszutragen. Und dann braucht es auch mal eine grundsätzliche ethische Festlegung. Und die ist bis heute halt gültig. Und bis heute auch, eigentlich kann man sagen, bewährt.
Ja, VAU Holland im Übrigen erwähnen wir an der Stelle gesondert, weil nachdem eine Stiftung benannt ist, die jetzt unter anderem für Wikileaks auch Spenden einsammelt. Also das passt auch alles so ins Gesamtbild ein bisschen.
Ja, naja. Und die Frage ist ja, warum betreibt man dann so eine Leaking-Plattform? Also was ist denn die Motivation dahinter, außer dass man vielleicht ein bisschen wahnsinnig ist und irgendwie die Welt retten möchte?
Auf Abschusslisten nennen möchte.
Und also Julien hat ja mal dann ein Artikel geschrieben.
Der hat mal einen Blog gehabt bei iq.org. Und also Wikileaks wird ja heute fast vollständig mit Julien Assange identifiziert, was unter anderem an Julien liegt und was man positiv und negativ sehen kann. Aber wir kommen also nicht drum herum, so ein bisschen die Figur zu beleuchten. Und Julien ist eigentlich ein Hacker aus Australien. Ein begnadeter Hacker übrigens. Der hat einen der ersten vernünftigen Podscanner geschrieben, die es so gab. Den Strobe hieß der. Und der Podscanner war rasend schnell. Also Größenordnung schneller als alles andere, was wir je gesehen haben bis dahin. Das war so 1990 oder so, als das echter war. Und Julien hat auch ein verschlüsselndes Fallsystemkonzept entwickelt namens Rubber Hose. Ich glaube, da gab es auch mal Quellcode. Den habe ich aber nie gesehen. Und da war die Idee, also Rubber Hose ist ein Gummiknüppel. Und da war quasi die Idee, wenn du deine Daten verschlüsselst und du kommst jetzt in ein repressives Regime, in ein Land, wie sagen wir China würde man heute sagen. Und die stehen mit einem Gummiknüppel hinter dir und sagen, hier gib mal das Passwort her. Dann hat Julian als Erster die Idee geäußert, dass man ein Fallsystem haben will, wo es ein Zweitpasswort gibt, was man denen dann geben kann und was auch Daten entschlüsselt, aber wo es keine Möglichkeit gibt, nachzuweisen, dass es nicht das Primärpasswort war. Also die Idee, dass man die Neubility braucht, würde man sagen. Also dass man leugnen kann, da Daten zu haben, die ist von Julian. Das ist bahnbrechend. Das ist heute ein Standard-Feature in verschlüsselnden Fallsystemen. TrueCrypt hat sowas zum Beispiel auch.
Ja, also den besseren verschlüsselnden Fallsystem.
Ja, es ging natürlich immer rammisch. Aber diese Idee geht auf Julian zurück. Also ich würde sagen, der Mann ist ein brillanter Hacker. Und schon am Anfang seiner Karriere konnte man deutlich sehen, dass er sich auch tiefschürfende Gedanken gemacht hat zu humanitären Fragestellungen und wie man die Welt verbessern kann. Der ist also kein reiner Egomane, der jetzt hier quasi sein Geschäftsmodell abzieht, um seine Persönlichkeit in die News zu bringen, obwohl das vielleicht auch ein Aspekt ist. Aber es ist also durchaus ein brillanter Hacker und ein sehr intelligenter Mann. Also wenn man sich mit dem unterhält, dann kann man tatsächlich Stunden damit füllen, anregende Gespräche zu führen.
Das ist einer der wenigen Menschen, bei denen man zu dem Schluss kommen kann, dass ein doch recht großes Ego durchaus einen Grund hat. Das sieht tatsächlich auch was dahinter. Ja gut, ich denke mal auf die Details, denn momentan Color Man-Titeln geben wir einfach nicht ein. Die werden irgendwie in den nächsten Wochen in so dermaßen der Detailtiefe durch die Presse gewälzt werden, das uns jetzt schon schlecht wird.
Kann er mal erzählen, wann ich ihn zuerst kennengelernt habe. Das war so, ich glaube, 1994 oder so. Und zwar kam er aus Russland angereist und zwar hat er einfach eine Weltreise gemacht. Allein das Faktum, finde ich schon, sagt so viel über eine Person aus. Der hat sie einfach hingestellt und gesagt, er gibt jetzt alles auf, was er zu Hause in Australien hat. Und packt das in einen Rucksack und macht eine Weltreise. Und auf dem Weg der Weltreise kam er eben auch durch Berlin und kam aus Russland an. Und wir haben ihn vom Flughafen abgeholt. Und er kam da in Shorts an und es war Winter. Also es war hier schon scheiße kalt. Und er kam aus Russland und meinte, wieso ist das auf Wabi? Also das war schon sehr bizarr. Aber immerhin, man sieht, dass er den Anspruch hat, auch die Dinge selbst gesehen zu haben, bevor er über sie spricht. Das fand ich also sehr sympathisch damals. Und er hat damals auch so ein paar Philosophien schon erzählt. Und die sind auch später in seinem Blog geblieben. Und das Blog gibt es leider nicht mehr inzwischen. Aber man kann noch die Fragmente davon auf archive.org sehen. Und das ist durchaus empfehlenswert. Also ein bisschen davon ist so sehr, wie soll man sagen, verquast formuliert. Aber die Grundidee ist eben, dass die Staaten und Regierungen, die uns regieren, die arbeiten ja eigentlich für uns. Aber in der Praxis basieren sie auf einem Hügel von Geheimnissen, ein großer Berg von Geheimnissen. Und die müssen geheim gehalten werden von dem eigenen Volk, für das man ja eigentlich arbeitet. Und daraus ergibt sich automatisch, dass die Regierung so eine Art Verschwörung wird. Denn die müssen jetzt zusammenarbeiten gegen das Volk, um die Geheimnisse geheim zu gehalten. Und das ist eigentlich kein guter Zustand, hat er gesagt. Und wenn man das angreifen will, dann kann man jetzt entweder versuchen, einzelne Fragmente, einzelne Leute im System anzugreifen, aber die werden dann halt ersetzt. Das führt nicht weiter. Oder man kann die Erhaltungskosten des Systems steigern, indem man an kritischer Stelle Sachen liegt. Also die Idee kam relativ früh auf. Wenn man jetzt aus einem System wie den US-diplomatischen Botschaften die Depeche liegt, dann werden die ihr Sicherheitssystem hochschrauben und sich gegenseitig nicht mehr trauen. Und das ist in einer Verschwörung natürlich tödlich, wenn sich die Leute nicht mehr trauen. Und dadurch werden die Kosten gesteigert. Und man sieht auch bei den Amis, sehr gut das funktioniert. Die haben erst mal die Zip-Net zugemacht und natürlich steigen dadurch die Kosten, wie die intern kommunizieren. Und da wird es dann auch keine, nicht mehr so viele Leute werden Zugang haben. Und das ist eine hervorragende Methode, um der Sand ins Getriebe zu streuen. Also die vorausgesagten Effekte treten deutlich ein. Das kann man auch gut sehen gerade.
Die Frage ist natürlich, mal den Advokat, Advokat des Diabolizium machen. An welcher Stelle ist nur Verschwörung, also wo da negatives Handeln innerhalb solcher Regierungen beeinflusst und negativ beeinflusst. Und an welcher Stelle halt wirklich die Regierungsfähigkeit landet. Also leitet einer der Kernargumente, die ja gerade jetzt gebracht wurde bei diesen Depeschen, ist ja, dass man halt keine Diplomatie mehr betreiben kann, wenn man nicht vertraulich miteinander reden kann. Und das, glaube ich, ist eine Sache, die noch mal in etwas ausführlicherer Betrachtung lohnt, um mal nachzuvollziehen, warum sind wir eigentlich zu diesem Punkt gekommen.
Das habe ich übrigens jahrelang geglaubt, dieses Argument. Habe ich jahrelang geglaubt, bis ungefähr letztes Jahr, als den Belgiern ihre Regierung weggebrochen ist. Denen ist einfach mal komplett die Regierung weggebrochen und die haben es nicht geschafft, eine neue zu bilden. Und es hat ein Jahr gedauert, bis sie eine neue Übergangsregierung haben. Und auch die ist überhaupt nicht irgendwie legitim, sondern irgendwie der König musste da einschreiten, um da eine Regierungsbildung herbei zu erzwingen. Und den Belgiern ist es dadurch nicht schlechter gegangen. Im Gegenteil, im Vergleich dazu, wie die anderen Länder in der Eurozone in der Zwischenzeit sich in den Boden gerammt haben, geht es denen sogar noch besser als keine anderen.
Na ja, aber gut, da kann man natürlich darum sagen, geht deswegen, weil Belgien so ein kleines Land ist und deren Wirtschaft im Wesentlichen auf Autopilot funktioniert.
Na ja, aber ist das bei uns nicht auch so? Also ich kann sagen, die drei Sachen, wo ich mal beobachtet habe, was passiert, wenn die Regierung eingreift, die sind halt nach hinten losgegangen, oder?
Na ja, klar, man kann sich natürlich den Standpunkt stellen, dass eigentlich möchte man da nur Leute haben, die dafür sorgen, dass irgendwie die Steuern eingetrieben werden und niemand einen größeren Scheiß baut. Interessant daran ist ja diese Abwägung, die da gerade passiert, warum die Regierung, also gerade die amerikanische Regierung, so dermaßen durchdreht. Und ich glaube, das hängt aber zusammen, dass die schon sehr deutlich sehen, wie denen ihre Fälle wegschwimmen. Es gibt ja da dieses alte Konzept aus der Frühzeit des Internet-Science-Fiction, der Crypto-Anarchy, also dem zu sagen, wir können alles verschlüsseln, also kann die Regierung da nicht mehr reingucken, also können wir auch beliebige Untergrundökonomien aufbauen, um an die Regierung vorbei, an Steuerzahlungen vorbei, an allem vorbei Parallelgesellschaften aufzubauen. Super.
Und dann wundern sie sich, dass keiner neue Straßen baut.
Genau, das ist halt genau der Punkt. Was passiert denn dann? Die Frage stellt sich halt immer, denn in solchen Zeiten ist es dann immer erst auf der letzten Seite und da ist das Buch leider schon zu Ende.
Ich heiße es immer, der gedeigte Leser kann sich ja Gedanken machen.
Genau. Und diese Diskussion kam auch hoch jetzt mit im Kontext mit diesem französischen Pamphlet, der kommender Aufstand. Hast du das gelesen?
Nee, aber ich habe die Berichterstattung darüber gelesen und fand es sehr gut.
Genau. Und die Diskussion war ja durchaus erhellend und einer der wichtigsten Anmerkungen fand ich eben, naja, also ja, die Analyse mag ja ganz treffend sein. Also die Idee sagt halt, die Institutionen werden destabilisiert und delegitimiert, weil sie niemandem mehr in glaubt. Also es gibt halt kein Vertrauen mehr in irgendwas, was die Regierung tut. Das haben wir doch jetzt schon, oder? Die Analyse stimmt ja. Es ist halt nicht so, dass es nicht stimmt. Also die Regierungen delegitimieren sich permanent selbst so. Selbst wenn jetzt plötzlich mal ein ehrlicher Politiker des Weges käme. Also wenn halt irgendwas passieren würde, dass...
Genau, dem glaubt auch keiner mehr.
Dem glaubt keiner mehr. Selbst jemand, der antragen...
Und woran würden wir ihn erkennen?
Wirklich, wenn? Selbst jemand wie Obama, der halt angetreten ist mit irgendwie, wo alle dachten so, naja, geben wir dem Mann mal eine Chance, weil vielleicht meint er sehr ehrlich, so wie er sagt, und vielleicht ist ja da auch was dahinter. Selbst der hat sich dann halt irgendwie die Banker da hingesetzt als Berater und irgendwie das Geld von den falschen Leuten genommen. Und am Ende sind die tatsächlichen effektiven Ergebnisse seiner Regierung vielleicht mit Ausnahme von der Krankenkassenreform recht überschaubar. Völlig überschaubar. Und wozu der Mann den Friedensnobelpreis bekommen hat, ist bis heute völlig unerklärt. Also es gibt keinen ernsthaften Grund dafür. Und die Szenarie, was tatsächlich in etwas strategischeren Regierungskreisen ernsthaft diskutiert wird, ist eben so ein Zerfallen der staatlichen Autorität. Und wie so was dann aussehen kann, sehen wir halt zum Beispiel in Mexiko. Was da gerade passiert mit den Drogenbanden, die halt einfach mehr Autorität und mehr Ordnungsmacht haben als der Staat.
Und die haben das Gewaltmonopol an sich gerissen.
Die haben das Gewaltmonopol an sich gerissen. Und die Amis haben einen Heidenschiss davor, dass ihnen das über die Grenze schwappt. Also dass ihnen da tatsächlich Teilbereiche...
Wobei die ja auch eigene Militärs haben, von denen man durchaus Angst haben könnte.
Ja, ja, eben. Aber das sind ja genau diese Zeichen, dass eben das Gewaltmonopol irrodiert, dass eben der Staat nicht mehr in der Lage ist, dafür zu sorgen, dass die Leute sich nicht gegenseitig auf den Kopf hauen.
Nee, was ich sagen will ist nicht, die haben nicht Angst davor, dass die Leute aus Mexiko kommen, sondern dass die Idee rüber schwappt.
Ja, die Idee natürlich. Und natürlich der Einfluss des Drogengeldes, der natürlich dahinter steht.
Das nutzen sie ja selber. Da machen wir auch noch mal eine Sendung zu. Versprechen wir jetzt halt.
Ja, stimmt. Wir machen auch mal eine Sendung zu Drogen und Drogenschmuggel. Hab dann wirklich wieder lustige Dinge über diese U-Boote gelernt, aber lassen wir das. Der Grund, warum die Amis jetzt so durchdrehen, ist eben genau dieser strategische Gedanke, dass sie vermuten, dass wenn es jetzt immer so weitergeht, dass die Institutionen, die da sind, nach und nach immer mehr entkleidet werden, in dem Sinne, dass halt niemand mehr auch nur den Ansatz eines Glaubens heben kann, dass die das da noch ehrlich meinen. Also dass tatsächlich unser zynischer Sicht, unsere zynische Sicht auf die Welt der Wahrheit entspricht, dass das halt zu einer Mainstream-Ansicht wird. Was passiert denn dann? Also wenn man dem Staat eben nicht mehr glauben kann.
Es gab letztes Jahr die Meldung, die ich ausgesprochen beeindruckend fand, im Kontext von der Bankenkrise. Da hieß es dann, jemand hat mal geguckt und hat gesehen, dass die Bankenbosse, die reichen Bänke, sich alle Zweitwohnungen in ärmlicheren Vierteln gekauft haben. Weil sie direkt befürchtet haben, dass jetzt der Lünchmob loszieht und sie umbringen will. Und dass sie dann aus Sicherheitsgründen irgendwo in ärmlichere Viertel ziehen, damit sie überleben können. Also das ist die Bedrohung noch deutlich stärker, als wir sie sehen. Die haben sich wirklich sorgen gemacht und machen sich wahrscheinlich immer noch wirklich sorgen. Und so erklären sich auch diese, es gibt ja da Geschichten von irgendwelchen Quarantänelagern, die irgendwo in der Wüste aufgebaut werden, wo irgendwie von der FEMA, der Katastrophenbehörde und so. Also man hört ja da alle Sachen, alle möglichen Dinge, die eigentlich überhaupt keinen Sinn ergeben, außer man beobachtet sie eben in diesem Kontext. Auch unsere Sicherheitsgesetze passen ja perfekt in den Kontext. Da geht es gar nicht darum, jetzt konkrete Sicherheitsprobleme zu lösen, die wir jetzt haben, sondern es geht um die Zukunft. Dass die einfach vor sich sehen, dass hier ihr Monopol auf die Wahrheit und auf die Vertrauenswürdigkeit am Irrhodieren ist. Und dass es irgendwann mal platzt und dann baut man lieber vor. Und früher hat man da eben Atombrucker gebaut für den Kohl, irgendwo in der Mosel. Und heute baut man da eben Sicherheitsinfrastruktur auf.
Ich denke mal einer der Gründe dabei ist, dass der Kern von sozialer Marktwirtschaft ist ja eigentlich, dass die Leute, die nicht genug Geld haben, weil die Systeme für ihre Arbeitskraft nicht genügend Geld zur Verfügung stellt, weil sie nicht genug Wert haben an Augen des Systems, dass die dafür bezahlt werden, ruhig zu bleiben. Und dass also der soziale Frieden erkauft wird.
Ein Gutteil übrigens durch Jobs in der Regierung. Also wir meckern immer, dass die Regierung so viele unüberflüssige Behörden hat. Aber damit haben sie sich die Arbeitsplätze erkauft.
Und das ist halt eben der Kern dieser Neokornideologie. Wozu eben auch die Abschaffung von relativ umfangreichen Staatsbehörden und Betrieben gehört. Und Betrieben in Landesbesitz, Stadtbesitz und dergleichen Dinge mehr. Die ja eben sozialen Frieden garantieren einfach dadurch, dass sie halt einfach gute Arbeitsplätze sichern. Besteht ja eben daran zu sagen, naja wir können doch viel von dem Geld von unten nach oben verteilen. Und den Rest lösen wir halt mit Sicherheitsgesetzen. Und dass eben genau diese Verschärfung der Sicherheitsgesetze und genau diese Verschärfung der allgemeinen Bedrohungslage ist eben genau die andere Seite der Neokornideologie. Da muss man sich halt nichts vormachen. Und das ist eben genau das, worum es jetzt gerade geht. So wie lange geht das noch weiter? Und an welchem Punkt platzt das? Und sind die dann in der Lage mit dem, was sie sich da aufgebaut haben, an Sicherheitsapparat in der Lage, das zu contain? Meiner Meinung nach nicht.
Na im Moment noch nicht, nee. Aber ich meine, sie arbeiten ja dran. Was glaubt ihr denn, wozu die eine DNA-Datenbank von uns brauchen? Da gibt es ja keine andere Erklärung für eigentlich. Das braucht man nicht, um Verbrechen aufzuklären. Totaler Blödsinn. Also ich habe ja so eine leicht andere Interpretation von dem, warum die Neokons sagen, sie möchten gerne die Regierung verkleinern. Wenn du nämlich mal guckst, was die Neokons und ihre vorgänger gemacht haben, die haben doch nie irgendeine Regierung verkleinert. Im Gegenteil, es ist immer mehr geworden. Ich glaube, das ist so eine Sache wie gegen Ausländer hetzen oder gegen die Arbeitslosen hetzen. Das ist so ein populistisches Ding, mit dem du an die Macht kommst, aber du machst es dann nicht. Sondern du sagst es nur, also ich meine, es fällt dir auch nur ein Vorschlag ein, ein konkreter Vorschlag ein, was die mal kürzen wollten.
Was denn so? Was die getan haben, ist, die haben die ganzen staatlichen und landeseigen Betriebe und unsere Infrastruktur, alles was privatisiert.
Ja gut, klar, aber das war ja schon vorher, oder nicht?
Nee, das ist ja der Anfang der Welle. Also diese Privatisierungswelle, also eben genauer dafür zu sorgen, dass einstmals funktionsfähige Systeme kaputt sind und nur noch aus Scheiß-Jobs bestehen. Also ich meine, guck dir, das andere hat da gerade passiert, ja. Also ich meine, dass Berlin jetzt endlich sein Wasser zurückkauft, das ist, finde ich, ein ausgesprochen gutes Zeichen. Ja, aber schon in jedes einzelne, also ich meine, es gibt kein einziges Beispiel, was mir irgendwie einfällt, wo so eine Privatisierung irgendwie durchweg positive Folgen gehabt hat.
Na, die Telekom wird immer gesagt, weil früher war es ja noch teurer.
Die positiven Folgen davon waren nicht durch die Privatisierung der Telekom, sondern durch die Liberalisierung des Telekom Marktes.
Natürlich. Aber ich will nur sagen, das wird immer hochgehalten. Also mir fällt auch keins ein. Lustigerweise ist ja die Privatisierung in England vor allem den Amerikanern zugute gekommen. Das fand ich sehr witzig und zwar deswegen, weil die Amerikaner nämlich von ihren Wasserwerken auch Profit erwartet haben, aber ihnen die Preise reguliert haben. Das heißt, die konnten den Profit nicht machen, indem sie unten natürlich Qualität vorgeschrieben haben. Das heißt, die konnten weder günstiger produzieren, weil sie dann die Qualität nicht eingehalten haben, noch die Preise erhöhen, weil das auch reguliert war. Und dann bleibt ihnen nur noch Investment woanders. Und die haben sich sofort auf ausländische privatisierte Wasserwerke gestürzt und haben da eben die Qualität runtergedreht und den Preis hoch. Lustigerweise, die Wasserwerke von London, das hatten wir vor ein paar Jahren mal in der Nordshow, gehören ja den Deutschen. Also es ist nicht so, als wenn wir jetzt immer hier ins Ausland zeigen. Im Wassermarkt sind ganz groß dabei die Franzosen und die Deutschen. Und die versuchen im Übrigen auch gerade in Nordafrika Fuß zu fassen.
Überall, wo Wasser knapp wird?
Na klar, aber also nein, nicht nur wo knapp wird, sondern sie wollten aktiv die Verknappung herbeiführen. Und da ist gestern so ein Ding gelesen auf German Foreign Policy. Da hieß es dann so ein Strategiepapier, was heißt, wir müssen mal dafür sorgen, dass der Staat aufhört das Wasser zu subventionieren. Das ist viel zu billig. Die Leute sollen zahlen für ihr Wasser. Natürlich würde das bei uns keiner sagen, sondern da erklärt man das dann mit irgendwelchen marktwirtschaftlichen Nukleabla.
Der Markt, genau.
Natürlich. Aber in internen Papieren sagt die durchaus die Wahrheit. Das würde ich mir auch mal wünschen, dass das geleakt wird. Nicht nur der Regierungsscheiß, sondern was die Firmen eigentlich denken.
Die spannende Frage ist, wenn wir jetzt auf so eine Zeit zugehen und danach sieht es ja offensichtlich aus, dass Leaking Standard wird. Egal, was man über Julian denkt und seine persönlichen Eigenschaften und Probleme und Umgang mit anderen Menschen sind möglicherweise nur nicht unbedingt, was man von seinem Schwiegersohn erwarten würde. Was er auf jeden Fall gezeigt hat, ist, dass das funktioniert. Also dass man halt, wenn man den Mut und die Technologie hat, dass man das tun kann.
Und dass man genau die Leute, die man ärgern wollte, auch so richtig doll ärgern kann.
Genau. Und was halt heißt, dadurch, dass es jetzt dieses Vorbild gibt, wird es danach auch mal geben. Also egal, was jetzt mit ihm passiert so und egal, wie sich dieser merkwürdige Personenkultur um ihn da jetzt irgendwie noch weiterentwickelt, klar ist halt, da wird es halt auch noch andere geben, die es halt versuchen und auch Projekte geben, die halt eben kein Gesicht in die Presse halten müssen, um zu funktionieren und dergleichen Dinge mehr.
Wichtiges Element.
Die Frage ist jetzt eben, wie gehen die Regierungen denn damit um? Also welche, also was sind die Alternativen? Und also wenn ich jetzt irgendwie in so einem Think Tank arbeiten würde, dann würde ich mir jetzt irgendwie mal ernsthaft anfangen, also wahrscheinlich eher schon vor fünf Jahren angefangen haben, Gedanken darüber zu machen, wie regiert man denn unter solchen Umständen? Also wie regiert man denn unter der Maßgabe, dass die Anzahl der Geheimnisse, die ich wirklich geheim halten kann, geringer wird? Also was ich halt einfach mir echt überlegen muss, welche Geheimnisse muss ich denn jetzt wirklich geheim halten, damit irgendwie noch regieren funktioniert, im Sinne, wie ich es halt haben möchte, also im Sinne von ganz neutral den Scheiß am Laufen halten?
Ich glaube nicht, dass sie das schon haben.
Nee, haben sie nicht.
Also nichts von vor fünf Jahren überhaupt. Das hat die gerade echt kalt erwischt. Das sieht man ja auch daran, wie hysterisch die da geworden sind. Also wenn man mal überlegt, haben die eigentlich alles falsch gemacht in ihren Reaktionen darauf. Also ich glaube ja inzwischen, dass ein Großteil der Sachen von Julien tatsächlich inszeniert wurde, damit sie da reinlaufen und das falsch machen. Also zum Beispiel, dass er das bei Amazon gehostet hat, ist doch ein totaler Schuss in den Ofen. Wie kann man denn Geheimnisse über die IS-Regierungen bei einer US-Firma hosten? Ist doch klar, dass es hochgeht. Aber wenn du mal einen Schritt weiter denkst, dann fällt dir auf, du, das ist doch perfekt, wenn die das runterfahren, dann delegitimieren sie sich doch weiter. Und der nächste Schritt hier, Postfinanz, da hat er einfach einen Wohnsitz angegeben, den es nicht gibt. Das ist ja auch grenzblöde.
Ich glaube, sie hat die Kanzlei von seinem Anwalt angegeben, las ich.
Ist ja egal. Also jedenfalls eine Adresse, die sich leicht als falsch verifizieren lassen konnte, hat er angegeben und da hätte es auch richtige Adressen gegeben. Also der Trick bei Julien ist gar nicht, dass er direkt die Leute angreift, sondern dass er ihnen genug Seil gibt, damit sie sich selbst hängen. Und das funktioniert prächtig. Die Leute laufen wie ein Reh im Scheinwerferlicht, laufen die einfach hysterisch von links nach rechts und gegen den nächsten Baum. Und das muss man wirklich sagen. Hut ab, Julien ist ein guter Schachspieler.
Das kann man nicht anders sagen. Die spannende Frage ist ja, warum ist die Presse mit dieser sehr gespaltenen Deutschland? Da gibt es halt irgendwie einmal den Spiegel, der sozusagen mit am Trog sitzt, der halt irgendwie seinen Deal gemacht hat, um Zugriff auf die Daten zu bekommen. Und dann gibt es noch so fünf andere Zeitungen weltweit, die es getan haben. Und bei den anderen, was war dein Lieblingsfreund Leinendecker von der Süddeutschen?
Den blühte ich ja mal für den investigativen Journalisten. Auch jetzt halte ich ihn nicht mehr für nicht-investigativen Journalisten. Der hat ja so ins Klo gegriffen neulich. Da gab es beim Deutschlandradio so ein Interview und der hat auch in seiner Zeitung Sachen veröffentlicht. Da habe ich so, oh Gott, das wählen.
Wie war da der Tenor?
Na der Tenor war so, ja das ist ja, also damit man gefährdet Menschen eben, also es gibt ja so, die US-Regierung hat ja so eine Liste von Argumenten.
Die Talking Points.
Genau, die haben ja die Talking Points. Das sind im Übrigen genau dieselben, die sie schon bei Ellsberg angewendet haben, bei den Pentagon-Papers, worauf er neulich in einer Presseerklärung hingewiesen hat. Exakt dieselben Dinge haben sie aus der Schublade geholt und haben gesagt, ja das gefährdet Menschenleben und bla, das ist unseriös und das kann man hier einfach tun und ein Terrorist und der muss irgendwie, und dann das Geld abdrehen. Das ist so eine Standard-Sache, was die mit allen machen, die sie nicht mögen. Und also das ist alles, nichts davon ist irgendwie jetzt entstanden, sondern alles, was sie gerne machen, sind Sachen, die sie eh schon immer gemacht haben. So, woraus ich schließe, dass sie überhaupt keinen Plan hatten, wie sie darauf reagieren sollen. Auch, dass sie hysterisch die Regierung vorher informiert haben, dass da jetzt was Schlimmes kommt. Das hat die Sache ja auch nur noch viel schlimmer gemacht. Weißt du, wir haben doch alle da gesessen und haben gedacht, naja, also wir wissen ja demnächst kommt da was von Wikileaks, aber das kann halt entweder groß sein oder nicht und alle eher so ambivalent. Und wenn dann die US-Regierung rumläuft und den ausländischen Botschaftern mitteilt, dass da demnächst was Großes kommt, das ist doch das Blödeste, was du tun kannst an der Stelle. Weißt du, das erweckt doch in mir als Leser erst das Interesse, mir das anzugucken. Also so bescheuert, ja. Die sind echt voll ins Messer gelaufen, was Julian ihnen hingelaufen, hingehalten hat.
Interessant daran war das, ich hab da mal mit Leuten geredet, die im deutschen Apparat da so ein bisschen mit zu tun hatten am Rande. Und interessant ist wohl, dass die amerikanischen Botschafter zum Beispiel aus Weinquellennachter rumgelaufen sind, gesagt haben, ja naja, also da kommt jetzt was und das ist irgendwie ein bisschen scheiße. Und da sind halt so Sachen, die wir so intern, ihr wisst ja, wie man intern so übereinander redet und so.
Das meinen wir nicht so, dass ihr alle doof seid.
Wir können euch jetzt nicht genau sagen, was da drin steht, weil zu dem Zeitpunkt wussten sie nicht, was kommen wird, wussten nicht, was rausgenommen, welcher Teil, wie es publiziert, haben sie keine Ahnung gehabt. Aber ihr wisst ja, wir sind ja Verbündete. Und bevor ihr irgendwas unüberlegt es tut, ruft uns doch bitte mal an.
Keine raschen Entscheidungen.
Und danach wurden dann in den Außenministerium einfach Task Forces gebildet, die mit dem Finger auf dem Reload-Button saßen die Wochenende über, bis dann wieder die ersten Daten kamen. Ich weiß nicht genau, inwieweit der Spiegel schon vorher dem Kanzler mal ein Exemplar geschickt hat.
Dabei ist das doch so überflüssig. Die sind doch alles Transatlantiker bis zum Anschlag. Da hättest du dir... Es gibt doch irgendwie nichts, was du hättest sagen können. Da wäre der nicht.
Also in Deutschland ist es ja so, dass die deutsche Regierung ist ja mehr oder weniger 50-50 gespalten, also zumindest der, der, die Apparat und die Bürokraten zwischen Nationalen und Atlantikern und die...
Na ja, also die Regierung jetzt?
Natürlich. Aber denkst du, warum wir gerade so gut Freunde mit Putin sind, nicht weil da alle Atlantiker sind? Ist schon so, dass das...
Na, weil unser Gas von da kommt.
Ja, weswegen sind es dann halt eben plötzlich keine Atlantiker mehr, wissen schon. Die Nadel im Arm kommt halt aus der anderen Richtung. Also das ist schon so, dass innerhalb der Regierung halt nicht alles Atlantiker sind, im Gegenteil. Da gibt es halt auch schon eine ganze Menge Leute, die keinen Bock mehr auf den großen Boden von überm Teich haben, zumal von dem halt auch immer weniger kommt. Also außer halt irgendwie irgendwelche Forderungen.
Durchhalte Parolen.
Forderungen durchhalte Parolen und auch die fragen, ob sie nicht mal die Truppen zur Verteilung des Opium-Preises nach Afghanistan schicken können.
Das gibt ja auch einen Zusammenhang, der irgendwie, ich freu mich schon auf diese Drogensendung.
Ja, die wird lustig. Ja, also insofern ist es schon so, dass es auch in unserer Regierung gibt es eine Menge Leute, die sitzen da gerade grinsend und drücken Reload. Und freuen sich jedes Mal, wenn da wieder was hochkommt. Weil es ist ja nicht so, dass diese Regierungen auf den Apparate-Ebenen nur aus irgendwie Leuten bestehen, die scheiße sind. Das ist ja nicht so. Sondern es ist ja eine Regel so, dass da häufiger Leute sind, die durchaus zumindest das wohlverstandene Interesse ihres Landes im Blick haben. So, meine, vielleicht ist deren Verständnis vom wohlverstandene Interesse ihres Landes ein bisschen distort. Aber jedenfalls nicht. Also die sind halt nicht aktiv scheiße. Und viele von denen, gerade die halt irgendwie in die Außenpolitik gehen, haben halt durchaus einfach einen positiven Blick auf die Welt und wollen einfach Sachen besser machen. Und naja, Westavalle ist da auch nicht sehr beliebt. Also ich meine, das ist halt irgendwie auch keine großartige Überraschung. Und wenn dann jemand mal irgendwie die Wahrheit sagt, also über Bande, also über drei Banden sozusagen die Wahrheit sagt, dann haben die natürlich da auch ihren Spaß dran. Und insofern ist halt auch der, ich denke mal, der Verfolgungsdruck außerhalb der amerikanischen Regierung jetzt bezüglich Wikileaks eher sehr gedämpft. So na klar gibt es da halt ein paar Skandale, die jetzt einigermaßen unangenehm sind. Und da werden halt ein paar Leute...
Das sieht man ja auch, dass kein einziges Land da jetzt irgendwie groß...
Außer Frankreich. Wahrscheinlich gab es da Depression, an denen Sarkosis wahre Körpergröße dran stand oder irgendwie sowas, oder die Höhe seiner Absätze erwähnt wurde oder so.
Na sie haben ihn ja relativ treffend charakterisiert, als irgendwie schwachen, kleinen Mann, der irgendwie Komplexe hat und seine persönliche, wie keine Kritik hören kann und so. Ich meine, das stimmt ja alles. So und ja, das hört er natürlich erst recht nicht gern, wenn es denn stimmt, dass er keine Kritik hört kann, so naja.
Naja, aber jedenfalls die interessante Frage ist ja eben, welches Verhältnis hat denn halt die, diese, ja der Regierungsapparat dazu? Und also klar gibt es da jetzt Leute, die meinen, das ist halt schon scheiße, wenn jetzt die Amis nicht mehr sich vertraulich und so weiter und so fort. Und irgendwie die, gerade die ganzen Atlantiker enttarnen sich halt einfach alle dadurch, dass sie eben solche Statements machen. Also du kannst halt irgendwie gucken, musst einfach nur gucken, wer das Maul hält und wer irgendwie sich aufregt und wer...
Wer zufrieden aussieht und breit grinset.
Immer Reload drückt, ja.
Und dann weißt du halt schon irgendwie, wer hier die Atlantiker sind und wer halt irgendwie noch die Interessen des Landes irgendwie im Blick hat. Und naja, und eben genau diese Presse-Strategie, die Wikileaks ja gefahren hat, ist ja einer gewissen Evolution unterworfen. Also das hat sich ja gezeigt, so am Anfang so 2006, 2007 haben die eine Menge Sachen gemacht, die durchaus Potenzial zu einem fetten internationalen Medien-Ding gehabt hätten. Also zum Beispiel die Scientology-Dokumente oder ja, was in Kenia da gelaufen ist und so. Da gab es ja endlos viele Sachen auch irgendwie. Was war mit dem, mit diesem BND-Dokument, was zum letzten Kongress war?
Also wir haben da einige Sachen verwertet.
Etliche Dinge dabei, so, ne?
Aber es hat halt nie wirklich so den großen Einbruch gehabt in der Presse. Und das lag daran, dass für die Presse so eine Quelle in der Sekunde verbrannt hat, verbrannt ist, wo alle Zugang haben. Weil dann ist es keine Exklusiv-Story mehr. Und interessanterweise wäre es ja trotzdem noch eine Exklusiv-Story, wenn sich denn mal einer finden würde, der darüber berichtet. Das heißt, sie machen sich das alle selber kaputt aus Angst, der andere könnte auch dran arbeiten. Was ja eine total schizophrenne Situation ist. Aber der einzige Ausweg, das hat Julien schon richtig erkannt, ist eben da Deals zu machen und denen eben doch wieder ihren Exklusiv-Dings zu geben. Und das ist natürlich eine philosophische Frage jetzt, ob das mit den Idealen von Wikileaks vereinbar ist oder nicht. Dass man eben nicht alles sofort allen liegt, sondern da wieder so eine Art kommerzielle, irgendwie künstliche Verknappung herbeiführt. Was ja eigentlich das Gegenteil dessen ist, was Wikileaks haben wollte.
Die Frage ist, ob die Aufmerksamkeitsschwelle, die durch kommerzielle konventionelle Medien erreicht werden kann, die ist ja offensichtlich immer noch so viel größer, dass es sich eben offensichtlich lohnt, wenn man diese Aufmerksamkeit haben will, eben sich auf deren Bedingungen einzulassen und deren eigentlich nicht mehr so richtig gut funktionierendes System hat, um noch ein Stück weiter zu verlängern auf der einen oder anderen Weise. Also Julian hat ja mal gesagt, dass das Ziel von Wikileaks ist, der Quelle zu garantieren, dass sie den größtmöglichen Impact erzielt, mit dem, was ihr da liegt. Und das macht er. Zumindest für die drei Sachen, die jetzt publiziert wurden.
Ja, aber...
Was liegen bleibt, sind halt die ganzen anderen Sachen. Er kann das versprechen, dass wir ihn nicht erfüllen.
Das kann man ihm schlecht vorwerfen.
Nee, es ist halt nur so ein Ding, das ist halt einfach so ein...
Irgendwann ist die Presse auch saturiert, ne?
Naja, das sehen wir ja gerade schon so. Also die Menge an Cables, die da kommt, ist ja nun so ein Trickle-Release, so irgendwie jeden Tag 50 oder 100 Stück.
Eigentlich sehr wenig, aber trotzdem schon zu viel, als dass irgendjemand sie tatsächlich durchliest.
Ja, naja, gut, also hängt davon ab, also die Zeitungen...
Na, aus so Junkies wie uns.
Die Zeitungen, die jetzt da am Mitmachen sind, die haben ja jeweils schon ihre eigenen Rubriken. Also Guardian zum Beispiel oder Spiegel und so, die haben ihre eigenen Rubriken, wo sie jeweils dann die Scandale recherchieren und so.
Sehr schön übrigens die Methode des Guardian, die haben wir jetzt gerade veröffentlicht, dass man ihnen doch Mail schicken soll, wonach sie greppen sollen. So, wenn jemand Ideen hat, was denn da noch für Skandale verbuddelt sein könnten.
Also da ist der Guardian ja doch den deutschen Medien sehr weit voraus, dass er seine Zuschauer auch online extrem mit einbezieht und einfach sagt, das haben sie ja angefangen mit den Geschichten zu den Expenses damals.
Ja, nicht nur das, also der Guardian linkt ja auch, der hat einen Blog über die ganzen Leaks gerade und linkt auch immer zu denen, die die anderen veröffentlichen. Was sich ja hier niemand trauen würde, weil die alle noch diesen 80er Jahre irgendwie Portalgedanken haben.
Die Leute müssen auf der Seite bleiben.
Genau, wir müssen die Leute auf unserer Seite halten, sonst klicken sie unsere Werbung nicht genug. So ein Blödsinn, aber das heißt ja für mich als Leser, dass ich, warum soll ich denn beim Spiegel anfangen, möchte da durchzuklicken, ja. Dann klicke ich doch lieber beim Guardian. Und der bizarre Effekt ist, dass ich natürlich der Guardian linked auf die englische Version vom Spiegel. Das heißt, die Depeche, die ich dann sehe, das sind die englischen Versionen im Spiegel. Und ich sehe gar nicht die deutsche Übersetzung. Was ich ja auch gut finde, weil der Spiegel ist ja völlig bescheuert und tut die Original-Depeche dann nicht hin, sondern einfach nur ihre fragmentarische. Und dann übersetzt, und da gab es ja auch schon die ersten Übersetzungen, die so nicht vollständig dem Original entsprachen. Ja, also diese Nummer zwischen Putin und Berlusconi haben sie doch eher unzureichend zusammengefasst im Vergleich zum Guardian.
Das war mir gar nicht aufgefallen.
Ja, also ich weiß nicht, der Spiegel verkackt da wieder nach Strich und Faden. Aber ich muss ja sagen, der Guardian hat mich jetzt echt überzeugt. Und bei mir kommen auch schon die ersten Mails an, ob ich denn weiß, wo man den Guardian bestellen kann als Abo. Mir schrieb einer, er hat gerade die Süddeutsche abgestellt und möchte jetzt schon jetzt den Guardian haben. Ob ich denn wüsste, wann ich den hier kriege?
Gut, das kriegen wir mal raus und tun es in die Links, weil ich glaube, das haben sie verdient.
Und ja, das kann ich auch nur sagen. Also ich muss sagen, ja, also ich denke auch, wir werden mal gucken, mit der Flatter-Kohle den Guardian mal ein bisschen zu finanzieren, weil das haben die echt verdient.
Das kann man nicht anders sagen. Die haben also tatsächlich von den traditionellen Medien momentan auch so eines der, wo man so das Gefühl hat, da haben Leute noch irgendwie einen Anspruch an das, was sie da tun. Na ja, aber interessant ist ja eben, dass dieser Effekt, dass die anderen Medien dann da so drauf eindreschen, dass der doch auch einen, also jetzt mal unabhängig von den USA, das ist natürlich auf jeden Fall so, aber dass der in Deutschland auch mir relativ stark zu sein scheint.
Ja, das ist so ein wirklich niederer Motive Futterneid einfach. Also gerade die Magazine, von denen man glaubt, sie hätten den Anspruch, das auch selber geleakt haben zu können. Gerade die sind wirklich am lautesten auch in der Kritik. Und besonders schizophren war eben an der Stelle der Leindecker, der ja früher mal beim Spiegel gearbeitet hat und offenbar seine Kollegen da nicht anpinkeln wollte. Und in diesem Deutschlandradio-Dings hat er also drei-, viermal wirklich penetrant, länglich ausgeführt, dass er das ja eine tolle Arbeit findet, was der Spiegel da macht. Und er hätte das ja gar nicht leisten können. So erzähl, erzähl. Aber so eigentlich ist er völlig unzufrieden und sehr angepisst, aber er kann jetzt hier den Spiegel auch nicht irgendwie groß kritisieren, weil das sind ja seine Freunde. Und das sag ich so, mein Gott, einfach mal die Klappe halten. Was soll denn das? Ich so, oh man. Und gerade so kleinere Medien, Blogs natürlich sowieso. Blogs haben ja in meisten Fällen gar nicht den Anspruch, da jetzt selbst die großen Enttündungsjournalisten zu sein. Auch ich ja nicht mit meinem Blog. Ich bin ja froh, wenn ich irgendwie meine Story finde, auf die link ich dann und dann ist gut. Also ich hab überhaupt nicht den Anspruch, jetzt jedem irgendwie hinterher zu recherchieren. Versuche ich natürlich in Sachen, die besonders krass aussehen, aber so im Großen und Ganzen sehe ich mich nicht als Konkurrenz zu Leuten wie dem Spiegel.
Dem Gegenteil, gerade bei dieser Datenmenge ist es eben auch richtig einfach, den Zugriff auf diese Daten zu haben, damit man eben Sachen finden kann, die einen selber interessieren. Also mich interessiert halt zum Beispiel gerade dieser ganze Kontext Stuxnet und die iranischen...
Ich würde natürlich keinen selber kreppen, na klar. Das ärgert mich auch, das sind die einfach alles im Netz.
Das würde ich heute eben auch gerne einfach gucken, sondern mal gucken, was beim Guardian da aus diesem dieser Zuschauer-Umfrage kommt.
Da werden wir uns auch mal beteiligen.
Ja, ich will mal ein paar Sachen submitten, die auf jeden Fall da eine Rolle spielen.
Aber es geht ja noch weiter. Das ist ja nicht nur, dass die Medien da so eine Art Futterneid entwickeln, sondern auch diese Transparenz-Forderung. Das hat mir ja schon angefangen, auf die Nerven zu gehen, als die Medien anfingen Wikileaks vorzuwerfen. Wikileaks sei ja nicht transparent. Welche Rolle spielt das denn bitte? Das ist eine Quelle für eure Nachrichten. Da könnt ihr ansetzen, recherchieren und da könnt ihr großartige Stories mitmachen und Geld verdienen. Wen interessiert denn, ob Wikileaks transparent ist? Was wollt ihr dann da hören? Die Gehälter, die die Julien kriegt? Welche Rolle spielt denn das? Ob der jetzt irgendwie 1000 oder 3000 Euro oder was auch immer kriegt oder gar nichts? Ändert das irgendwas an dem Informationsgehalt der Depecheon, die er da veröffentlicht? Also totaler Bullshit.
Aus meiner Sicht wird es mich beruhigen zu wissen, dass er irgendwie genügend Geld bekommt. Aus dem einfachen Grund, weil...
Ja, damit er nicht angreifbar ist, klar. Damit er sich...
Ja, naja und vor allen Dingen...
Wenn die nicht mit ein paar Dollar irgendwie...
Das ist eben halt auch wie bei den Abgeordneten. Also eigentlich möchte man eben sicherstellen, dass so eine Plattform geradezu luxuriös finanziert ist, um sicherzustellen und zwar unabhängig luxuriös finanziert ist, eben aus Spenden, um sicherzustellen, dass sie irgendwie keinerlei Notwendigkeit haben, um halt irgendwie schattige Deals zu machen.
Ja, ich wüsste ja gern, ob die Medienpartner Wikileaks Geld geben gerade für die Depeschen. Ob das Teil von dem Deal ist oder nicht, das würde mich echt mal interessieren.
Keine Ahnung, also Daniel sagt ja ja. Ich hab keine Ahnung, ich weiß nicht genau. Also es wird sich vermutlich irgendwann rausstellen.
Nee, weil weißt du, das finde ich in dem Kontext, weil die immer alle rumbäschen auf der Warholland-Stiftung, und so von wegen macht da mal Rechenschaftsbericht. Und keine Sau fragt, ob der Spiegel eigentlich Geld abdrückt. Weil das ist doch wahrscheinlich viel mehr Geld und vor allem ist es nicht projektgebunden. Die Warholland-Stiftung ist ja eine gemeinnützige Stiftung, das können wir vielleicht mal kurz erläutern. Das ist nicht so, dass Julien dahin geht und sagt, gib mir mal 10 Euro, ich brauch eine Currywurst, sondern da kannst du nur mit einer Quittung hingehen über eine Sache, von der du begründen kannst, warum sie für das Projekt notwendig ist und den Satzungszielen der Warholland-Stiftung entsprechen. Und dann kriegst du nachträglich das zurückerstattet. Also da ist nix mit irgendwie, der macht sich da ein luxuriöses Leben und fliegt business-klar, ist so Bullshit. Das heißt, die Kohle, der man eigentlich hinterherrecherchieren müsste, wenn es wirklich um Transparenz ginge, ist die, die Leute wie Guardian und Spiegel Wikileaks zahlen und da fragt keiner nach. Und es geht ja noch weiter in diese Transparenz-Debatte. Der neueste Schritt ist ja, dass die Medien die Transparenz von Regierung und Wikileaks fordern, selber völlig untransparent sind. Also der Spiegel zum Beispiel, der hat es ja überhaupt nicht nötig, da auf die Original-Depeschen zu verlinken.
Das ist ja auch eine Transparenz-Sache. Vor allen Dingen liegen sie halt überhaupt nicht offen, nach welchen Kriterien die ausgewählt werden, welche Sachen zensiert werden, also welche Sachen da...
Ob da was fehlt, genau.
Ob da was fehlt, das wird halt in keiner Weise öffentlich gemacht. Und wie sich das dann irgendwie im Verhältnis zu ihren Anzeigenkunden darstellt, würde mich dann halt auch mal interessieren.
Das kannst du natürlich nur selber herausfinden.
Ja, naja, bloß, ich meine, es ist halt so, also wenn jetzt die Leute hingehen und sagen so, hey, wir wollen mal wissen, dass Wikileaks jetzt nicht für den iranischen Geheimdienst arbeitet oder was auch immer, oder für die Russen, dann kann man nur sagen, hey, wollen wir dann wissen, dass ihr nicht für die Russen arbeitet oder für Gazprom oder whoever, ja? Also ich meine, so wenn man sich die Berichterstattung in einigen Medien hier so anguckt, dann ist der Verdacht schon sehr deutlich, dass es da irgendwie Leute mit irgendwie zweiten und dritten Gehältern gibt, so.
Na, es gibt da einen Großteil der Spielwerbung, ist ja auch von der Autoindustrie und von der Energiemafia. Also da musst du gar nicht mit Drittgehältern anfangen. Das ist einfach die Werbekunden, von denen sind ziemlich genau die...
Da ging es mir jetzt halt primär um die Geheimdienste.
Ja, klar, nee, ist schon klar.
Zweitgehältern arbeiten, so.
Aufwandsentschädigung.
Und ich meine, gut, ein Gutteil der ganzen Geschichte entzündet sich halt einfach daran, dass Julian halt eine, persönlich halt nun eine relativ kontroverse Figur ist, die, ja, also...
Und auch sehr darauf bedacht ist, sich in die Öffentlichkeit zu stellen.
Ja, und das ist halt so ein bisschen, was mich auch gerade ein bisschen ankotzt, ist dieser Personenkult, der sich da gerade so entwickelt. Also es ist halt, also ich mag ihn halt sehr persönlich. Was mein, wenigen Kontakten mit ihm kann ich sagen, dass er halt ein interessanter und intelligenter Gesprächspartner ist. Aber dieser Personenkult, der sich da gerade entwickelt, da habe ich doch eine große Aversion. So, auch jetzt im Kontext...
Da kann er nur bedingt was für, glaube ich. Also er... Ich glaube, ehrlich gesagt, dass er dann...
Die prinzipielle Idee halt zu sagen, dass dieses Wikileaks ein Gesicht braucht, was sich halt irgendwie in die Presse stellt, finde ich schon debattierend surdig. Also es gibt Argumente dafür, meiner Meinung nach überwiegen die Argumente dagegen.
Du meinst, Nonimus hat auch kein Gesicht.
Ja, eben, funktioniert auch so. Na ja, aber...
Durch ein DDoS halt, ne?
Na ja, Gott, ich meine, Wikileaks kein Gesicht, ne, Wikileaks hatte kein Gesicht. Wieso sollte das nicht funktionieren?
Na, weil die Presse nicht mit dir reden will.
Natürlich redet die Presse mit dir, wenn du hinkommst und sagst, ich hab hier irgendwie den ganzen Scheiß.
Na, aber die möchten dich kein Interviewen.
Nee, was das ist, ist diese Boulevardisierung.
Na, da können wir nun nicht viel gegen sagen hier mit unserem Boulevard-Podcast.
Wir führen immerhin hier keinen Personenpult.
Also nur ganz wenig.
Das finde ich gerade eine Sache, die mich ein bisschen anüdet. Das wird jetzt natürlich noch sehr viel schlimmer, wenn jetzt nach seiner Verhaftung, wo halt einfach die Theorien ins Kraut sprießen, was jetzt an Schweden passiert ist und nicht passiert ist und ob man es ihm zutrauen kann oder nicht zutrauen kann. Da sagen wir nichts zu, was er auch nicht möchte. Einfach in den nächsten Wochen, wenn wir wird, wie gesagt, über uns rollen, diese Newslawine. Und da hab ich jetzt schon Grusel vor. Jedenfalls der Punkt, dass Julian halt offensichtlich ein Problem damit hat, irgendwie mit Leuten umzugehen. Also lässt sich ja schon allein daraus sehen, wie groß die Anzahl von von volunteers ist, die jetzt halt etwa nicht mehr irgendwie für Wikileaks arbeiten, die abgehauen sind. Was halt eben darauf hinweist, dass er so brillant auch sein mag, irgendwie möglicherweise eben nicht der begnadete Menschenführer ist. Der halt einfach irgendwie in der Lage ist, Leute länger bei der Stange zu halten, sondern halt eben sein eigenes Igbole nach vorne stellt und in die Presse schiebt. Das ist halt eine Sache, die kritisierenswert finde und wo ich halt einfach lieber eine Strategie hätte, die eben nicht so auf ihn zugeschnitten ist und so... Also ich meine, die interessante Frage wird jetzt halt sein, wenn er im Knast sitzt, ob Wikileaks in der Lage sein wird, das zu kompensieren. Also ob es tatsächlich der Christian Hafransen, der jetzt der neue Sprecher ist, ob der in der Lage sein wird, das entsprechend zu managen, dass die Voluntäres bei der Schlange bleiben, dass das Publizieren weitergeht. Und ja, also die Credentials von Wikileaks nicht nur darin bestehen, dass sie Julian als Goyonsfigur haben.
Der wird wahrscheinlich erstmal unter Presseanfragen zusammenbrechen. Erstmal ein DDoS auf das isländische Telefonsystem.
Das ist natürlich auch so ein Problem. Die Bandbreite in Form von Personen, also von wie viele Leute sind da, die anfragen, bearbeiten können, sich um Saucen kümmern können, um Cleaning und dergleichen Dinge mehr, ist natürlich die kritische Ressource. Also wie viele Leute sind da eigentlich, die Arbeit leisten können.
Sie haben ja keine neuen Saucen mehr. Sie sitzen auf einem riesen Haufen von...
Bloß allein den abzuarbeiten. Den abzuarbeiten brauchst du ja. Ich glaube, der Grund, warum die momentan eine 50 bis 100 Depression pro Tag raustun, ist eben, dass sie sich verpflichtet fühlen, da die Namen raus zu editieren. Und dass sie halt einfach nicht genug Leute haben, um das Editieren zu bewerkstelligen.
Wobei, das machen doch aber die Redaktionen der Zeitung. Der Leyendecker hat mehrfach erwähnt, der Spiegel habe eine eigene Taskforce mit 50 Personen, die einfach nur Depression auswerten und hinterher recherchieren. Und das ist, glaube ich, also ich habe da jetzt keinen Einblick, aber das klingt für mich mehr als Wikileaks überhaupt je an Mitarbeitern hatte.
Na gut, sie haben schon eine Menge Freiwillige, glaube ich. Aber Freiwillige ist natürlich etwas anderes, als wenn du dafür bezahlt wirst den ganzen Tag, irgendwie so einen Job machst.
Ja, also 50 Leute, ich meine, da könnte man schon eine Menge bestellen.
Vielleicht war das ja die Bezahlung. Also dass sie halt einfach kein Geld zugesagt haben, sondern Manpower.
Das kann natürlich auch sein.
Was clever wäre, wiederum. Auf der anderen Seite natürlich auch die Integrität beeinflusst. Weil, wenn ich mir jetzt so angucke, wie umfangreich die Editierungen sind an den Depressionen, die rauskommen.
Na nicht nur das, auch was die da, dass sie jetzt irgendwie Bruno den Problembär hervorzahren und nicht über Nordkorea und den Iran reden, das hat mich schon ein bisschen irritiert.
Und sowohl die Auswahl als auch die Art und Weise der der Löschungen daraus, finde ich jetzt erstmal nicht unproblematisch. Also da sind halt einfach, also woher weiß ich, nach welchen Kriterien uns dann Namen gelöscht werden, welche Namen, also was ist das Schutzbedürftigkeitskriterium, was da drin ist?
Also da bestehe ich jetzt erstmal auch nicht drauf in erster Linie. Ich würde ehrlich gesagt als Algorithmus nehmen, alle Namen zensieren, raustun und nachträglich, wenn jemand über den Stasi-Behörden, dann kannst du hingehen und sagen, ich bin hier Betroffener oder mich interessiert ist und dann kannst du im Einzelfall abwägen. Das ist glaube ich weniger schlimm.
Also meine Heuristik würde eine andere sein. Die erste wäre, ich würde erstmal alle meine Newsticker und mein gesamtes Newsarchiv nehmen, was ich habe als Zeitung oder als Spiegel.
Erstmal eine Whitelist von den Ehen in der Presse.
Und davon den Namen, die sowieso gewhitelistet sind. Und die halt einfach, die sind halt drin, die bleiben halt drin. Und dann bei allen anderen gucken wir dann mal. So, also, ist halt auch eine schwierige...
Ist halt doof, wenn es mehr als ein Kasei in Afghanistan gibt.
Ja, na gut. Aber halt zum Beispiel, warum jetzt halt irgendwie der Name von diesem FDP-Mäulwurf...
Warum der jetzt geheim bleiben sollte?
Warum der jetzt geheim bleiben sollte, kann man debattieren. Also ist halt irgendwie so ein... Auf der einen Seite kann man sagen, okay, das ist möglicherweise seine Privatsphäre, aber andererseits ist das halt eine Sache, die eigentlich in die Öffentlichkeit gehört zumindest, meiner Meinung nach.
Das sollten wir auch noch mal kurz erklärend konkretisieren, was Privatsphäre eigentlich ist. Eine Privatsphäre ist was, was Personen haben.
Keine Staaten.
Keine Staaten, keine Regierung und keine Firmen. Firmen haben keine Privatsphäre.
Die haben nur Geheimnisse.
Genau. Datenschutz betrifft die Privatsphäre, betrifft nicht irgendwie Geheimnisse des Staates. Da kann man irgendwie mit Geheimhaltung argumentieren, aber das ist eine deutlich schwächere Position.
Und andere Kriterien.
Ja, also da gibt es womöglich auch Gründe, das wäre debattierenswert, irgendwelche Militärstrategien oder so. Aber naja.
Na ja, bloß eben genau die Art und Weise, wie da editiert wird und wie die Namen da rausgelöscht werden und so weiter und so fort. Da hätte ich zumindest erwartet, dass es ein Policy Statement gibt.
Ja, in der Tat.
Also das ist halt einfach eine klare Ansage, wir editieren Namen aus diesen und jenen Gründen raus. Also das sind die Gründe, die wir uns als Mission Statement, eben auch von den Redaktionen, die offensichtlich dann die Arbeit machen, auferlegt haben und nicht nur so ein... Also beim Spiegel gab es da so eine Murukki-Formulierung, die da lautete, ja, wir haben ja mit der Regierung Kontakt aufgenommen und dann haben die uns gesagt, was sie irgendwie geheimhaltenswert fanden und an einigen Stellen haben wir ihnen zugestimmt, an anderen nicht. Ja bitte, welche denn? So was sind da jetzt die Kriterien? Also an welchen Stellen sagt ihr, wie finden wir schützenswert? Und das ist halt eben so ein Ding.
Wahrscheinlich der Chefredakteur seine Geheimdienstkumpels angerufen.
Und wenn sich Zeitungen eben so hinstellen und in so einer Selbstherrlichkeit agieren, dann kann ich irgendwie deren Rufe nach irgendwie Wikileaks soll mal total transparent sein, entspannt ignorieren. So weil denen fehlt einfach die moralische Grundlage für so einen Anspruch zu sagen, Wikileaks muss jetzt aber vollständig transparent sein. Ich meine Herrgott, dass eine Organisation hinterher gerade die verdammten USA hinterher sind, da kann man schon verstehen, dass die ein gewisses Gräbenhaltungsbedürfnis haben.
Und wonach Attentat durch Geheimdienst und ähnliche Dinge gerufen wird in den USA. Also wenn die haben noch ein höheres Geheimnisbedürfnis als die Spiegelredaktion, die ja von sich aus auf Quellenschutz sozusagen keinen Wert legt, wie wir vorhin besprochen haben. Also ich möchte auch noch mal kurz den Advokatus Diabolis spielen bei Assange, dass er sich so ins Zentrum schiebt. Denn das hat ja auch durchaus gute Aspekte. Also man kann auch argumentieren, dass er sich als Blitzerbleiter hinstellt, als einzige Person von Wikileaks, damit wenn die jemanden verfolgen, sie dann ihnen verfolgen und nicht die anderen. Und wenn man das damit koppelt, dass er selbst eigentlich gar nichts macht in der ganzen Sache, sondern dass er irgendwie nur der Name ist, dann ist das eigentlich schon eine gute Strategie. Also ich glaube, das ist jetzt so ein bisschen entgleist, aber als Idee finde ich das durchaus gut.
Ich finde das vorher sackbar entgleist. Also das ist halt einfach ein...
Na klar, also ich meine, nachvollziehbar. Also menschlich finde ich das nachvollziehbar, dass ihm das zu kopp steigt. Aber die Idee, dass er sich hinstellt und sagt, ich bin jetzt hier der Blitzableiter, damit sie keine chinesischen Dissidenten verhaften, sondern auf mich irgendwie losgehen, das finde ich, also ich weiß nicht, ob ich das an seiner Position gebracht hätte.
Nein, eigentlich nicht.
Ja, eher nicht. Also da muss ich schon eine Hochachtung für aussprechen, muss ich einfach mal sagen.
Naja, also für mich ist es hochreich zielspaltig aus dem Grund, weil wenn, dann muss man halt offensichtlich aber auch sicherstellen, dass man halt irgendwie keine Dinge tut, weswegen man dann hinterher irgendwie da an Probleme gerät, die halt irgendwie nichts mit Wikileaks zu tun haben.
Nein, ich denke, dass das echt ein Fehler war. Das wusste ich einfach nicht. Das ist so meine persönliche Vermutung, aber keine Ahnung.
Naja, und die Schwierigkeiten, die jetzt dadurch entstehen, sind eben, dass die ganze Story halt eben weggeht von Wikileaks-Story hin zu Julian-Story.
Das hätten sie aber glaube ich eh gemacht, selbst wenn es da jetzt keine schwedischen Anklagen gäbe.
Weiß ich nicht genau, ob das so gut gelungen wäre. Weil ich meine, stell dir mal vor, gäbe es auf jeden Fall. Stell dir vor, gäbe da jetzt nichts, dann gäbe es halt auch einfach keine Zwiespaltigkeit.
Du, die sind bei seinem Sohn in Australien aufgeschlagen und bei seiner Mutter, die ja alle seit Jahren nicht mehr gesehen hat, um sie zu schützen, und haben die interviewt, wie sie denn die Lage einschätzen. Also, die gehen beliebig weit, um ihren Boulevardrang zu füllen. Das finde ich kein gutes Argument. Und an der Stelle, also wie gesagt, ich muss sagen Hut ab vor Julien an der Stelle, dass er sich da so zur Verfügung stellt für die Sache. Ja, also ernsthaft, hätte ich glaube ich nicht geschafft.
Nee, gut, ich auch nicht, aber ich finde, wie gesagt, so eine Konzentration auf so eine Person, auf so einen Zuschnitt von einer Story auf so einen Personenkult, finde ich einfach scheiße. Das ist halt einfach, das muss zwangsläufig entgleisen.
Na, aber guck mal, wie viele Interviews hat der denn gegeben? Also weniger als der Vesterwelle so gibt und dem wirft auch keine Personenkult vor im Außenministerium.
Nee, aber das ist ja die Art und Weise, wie diese Story jetzt daherkommt.
Na, kann er da was für? Also er kann natürlich was für die Vorwürfe ausspielen.
Guck mal, wenn er in der Lage ist, irgendwie zu arrangieren, dass die Postfinanz an den Konsult zu machen. Also wenn er in der Lage ist, solche Traps zu setzen, dann treu ich ihm auch wirklich zu, dass er irgendwie sehr wohl wusste, was er da tut, wenn er sein Gesicht da irgendwie als Geheunensfigur heraushält.
Aber das war auch nicht zu vermeiden, wir haben ihn ja auf dem Kongress gehabt, und da gibt es ja auch Video-Footage von.
Das war dann anders als das, was dann passiert ist.
Guckt ihr doch mal, wo sie die Fotos jetzt gerade her haben. Das war größtenteils die Pressekonferenz, die er gegeben hat zu den Collateral-Mörder-Dings. Und ansonsten kursiert jetzt gerade dieses Bild von ihm im Polizeiauto, als er abgeführt wird. Man kann ihm nicht irgendwie vorwerfen, dass er sich ständig der Presse zeigt.
Es gibt schon eine Menge Interviews mit ihm, mit irgendwie ordentlichen, schicken Porträtfotos. Da gibt es reichlich.
Na, aber das ist ja auch was anderes als irgendwie... Also es ist nicht so, dass er da irgendwie... Wie viele Interviews hat er? Ich hab von ihm so ein Dutzend gesehen, wenn es hochkommt.
Aber die waren alle groß. Also das waren alle große Interviews mit irgendwie ordentlichen Zeitungen.
Aber das willst du doch auch.
Na ja, wie gesagt, ich fände halt einfach... Brauchen wir glaube ich nicht weiter diskutieren. Ich binde halt einfach der Meinung, dass ein Wikileaks, was halt eben gesichtslos wäre, einfach besser wäre und doch besser funktionieren würde und weniger Anlassfläche bieten würde.
Und wie erklärst du dann deinen Standpunkt, wenn jemand dich irgendwie doof von der Seite anranzt, wie der gefährdet Leben von US-Soldaten im Ausland?
Na ja, wie man so...
Kannst du trotzdem eine Presseerklärung raushauen?
Na natürlich.
Aber du kannst es doch beim CCC auch gut sehen. Ich meine, wir machen auch Presseerklärungen, aber da muss immer ein Name dranstehen, sonst kommt es nicht. Die Leute wollen, dass da ein Name dransteht. Da hätte man sich natürlich gerne ausdenken können.
Das wäre natürlich eine coole Strategie.
So ein japanisches 3D-Idol, einfach so ein Fake-Ding.
Die offensichtliche Strategie wäre so eine... Wissen Sie Hiromu-ti oder Hiromati? Oder wie heißt diese japanische 3D-Animations-Popstar? Das wäre genau das, was ich dazu bevorzugen würde. Da sucht man sich einen ordentlichen Animationskünstler und dann...
Das wäre natürlich echt geil gewesen.
Wikileaks 3.0 wäre doch mal ein echter Ansatz, so mal sowas zu machen. Weil dann würden sie, glaube ich, echt ganz schön doof dastehen. Weil dann gibt es halt eben eine Persönlichkeit.
Wie willst du den verhaften, wenn er irgendwie die Grenzen überschreitet? Aber wer macht die Pressekonferenz? Machst du dann auch ein Video oder was?
Stellst du ein Projekt dahin und bist fertig?
Super.
Also das fände ich mal eine...
Das wäre in der Tat... Ich glaube, dann würden einige Leute neue Hosen brauchen, wenn so ein Pressrelease kommt und ihnen da ihre Leaks...
Und dann noch so ein hübsches, japanisches, großäugiges Manga-Gerl. Außerdem könnte es irgendwie auch keine doofen Fehler irgendwo in Schweden machen.
Das stimmt.
Ja, also, wie ihr seht, kontroverse Diskussionen um dieses Thema, wo wir uns auch nicht so ganz einig sind, was aber auch ganz gut ist, weil dann sind die Diskussionen eigentlich immer am besten.
Das will man ja auch nicht, dass sich alle einig sind.
Wo kämen wir denn dahin, wenn wir jetzt hier Harmonie hätten?
Die Garniensache, wir hatten erwähnt, dass sie so eine Wonach-würdet-i-dann-suchen-Nummer hat. Wir haben uns ja auch mal Gedanken gemacht, wonach wir eigentlich suchen würden. Das ist jetzt keine erschöpfende Liste.
Ich würde auf jeden Fall erst mal nach so allen Namen von so Rüstungskonzernen, Ölunternehmen, Tacos, Defense Contractors, so was wie... Heliburton, Dünnkorb, Siemens und so suchen.
BAE.
Ja, stimmt. BAE, EADS und so. Also diese ganze...
Boeing, genau.
Ja, die Airbus und so. Also diese ganze... Überall wo große Mengen Geldes im Spiel sind, bei staatlichen Contracts, da könnten diese Dinger wirklich ergiebig sein. Ich hoffe, da guckt mal jemand nach. Und überhaupt auch diese ganzen Rüstungsgroßprojekte, also was halt da irgendwie so an, keine Ahnung, Aufklärungsflugzeugen, Satelliten und dergleichen Dinge ist, da gibt's garantiert irgendwie lustige...
Ja, genau, so was wie irgendwie Baikonur oder so, wäre vielleicht auch mal spannend.
Ja, zum Beispiel so.
Was lauschen die da eigentlich gerade?
Ja, aber auch so das Gerangel, bevor sie zum Beispiel irgendwelche neuen Intelligent-Systeme irgendwie in Betrieb nehmen und so. Ich weiß nicht, nur bis Secret, keine Ahnung, was da drin wäre, vermutlich nicht.
Na ja, Secret slash NoFawn ist schon ziemlich stark.
Ja, aber gut, ich glaube, die ganzen wirklichen Hardcore-Intelligent-Sachen sind halt schon eher ein Top Secret.
Ja, aber das reicht ja, wenn irgendwie ein, zwei versehentlich.
Naja, stimmt. Oder halt irgendwie indirekt was zu sehen ist. Denn natürlich irgendwie gucken nach diesen ganzen Beratungsunternehmen und Think Tanks und wie sie alle heißen, also die da halt Politik beeinflussen und Politiksthingen tun, die halt irgendwie nicht so ganz der Öffentlichkeit zu tauglich sind.
Genau, so relativ wie die Bertelsmann Stiftung oder Friedrich Naumann Stiftung, die im Ausland aufgefallen sind, weil sie in Lateinamerika Regierungen zu stürzen versuchen angeblich. Also so was, da kann man bestimmt tolle Erkenntnisse gewinnen. Und mich persönlich hätte ja noch der Chavez interessiert und Venezuela und so, diese Fark-Rebellen. Da gab es jetzt gerade eine Depesche aus Thailand, die sehr witzig war.
Aus Thailand mit den Fark-Rebellen? Mit Baut oder was?
Genau, es ging um Baut.
Also Baut war dieser Waffenschmuggler, der die Vorlage war für den Film Lord of War.
Ein ganz unglaublicher, ein Vita hat der Typ. Also das kann ich jedem nur empfehlen, sich mal die alleine die Wikipedia-Seite zu dem durchzulesen. Das ist wirklich sehr erhellend. Und der sitzt also seit Jahren in Thailand im Knast, wo sie ihn verhaftet haben. Ursprünglich ist der Mann wohl Russe. Und die Amis wollen ihn halt ausgeliefert haben. Und dann gab es halt so ein Gerichtsverfahren in Thailand, wo der Richter gesagt hat, naja, also nach unserem Recht ist Fark keine Rebellengruppe, sondern politisch. Und damit hat er nicht Waffen an Rebellen geliefert, sondern einfach nur irgendwie Waffen geliefert. Und das ist erst mal nicht direkt strafbar. Und damit ist also die Grundlage für die Auslieferung an die USA hin. Und das hat die US-Botschaft also hart getroffen. Da gibt es ein ganz hervorragendes, eine ganz hervorragende Depesche dazu, wo der Botschafter zurückschreibt, wir haben ihnen ausdrücklich versichert, was das für unglaubliche Konsequenzen haben wird. Und der Richter hat sich geirrt. Der Richter ist völlig falsch. Der hat es total falsch beurteilt alles. Und der hat doch das so und so Gesetz verletzt, was natürlich ein US-Gesetz ist und kein thailändisches Gesetz. Aber so diese Denke von wegen, das ist unser Gesetz, das gilt jetzt gefährlichst auch in Thailand, das ist halt sehr witzig zu beobachten. Naja, und da ging es unter anderem um die Frage, ob FARC jetzt eine Terroristenvereinigung ist oder nicht. Und das wird mich schon interessieren, was es da noch für andere Memos gibt mit irgendwelchen Leuten, die mit denen verhandelt haben oder auch nicht.
Na, denn dieser ganze Komplex Libanon, Israel, Syrien, Palästinenser ist auf jeden Fall vermutlich nicht.
Daher trinkst du wahrscheinlich einen Memos.
Ja, vermutlich trinkt man das.
Aber zumindest diesen syrischen Reaktor, den Israel da zerbombt hat, der angeblich ein Atomkraftwerk werden sollte oder irgendwie eine Anreichungsanlage oder so was. Also das hätte mich schon interessiert, zumal vorher, was irgendwie vor der Bombardierung da für Memos gewesen sind.
Also ob es in der Geheimnistruktur überhaupt welche gab, weiß man nicht, aber ja.
Ja und natürlich Gaddafi fürs Popcorn so. Weil der ist einfach immer, immer wieder für Popcorn gut. Also wir als CCC werden auch häufig gefragt, ja so gerade jetzt so, wie wir den Wikileaks einordnen, wie wir zu denen stehen. Und manche Medien haben sogar überhaupt nicht verstanden, dass wir überhaupt nicht Wikileaks betreiben, sondern bei manchen Leuten gibt da echt Missverständnisse. Und deswegen haben wir vorhin die Hackerethik erwähnt, um zu sagen, dass es eigentlich mit unseren Grundsätzen schon über einen Stimmung, über Lappungen gibt. Aber wir betreiben Wikileaks nicht. Und wir würden es auch nicht betreiben. So, wenn jetzt irgendwie Julian im Knast sitzt und sagt, hey CCC, wollt ihr nicht, da wären wir auch erstmal nicht in Versuchung.
Das ist nicht so direkt unsere Aufgabe, also Wikileaks ist ja eine Implementierung des Grundsatzes der Informationsfreiheit. Also zu sagen, jeder hat das Recht, sich aus beliebigen Quellen zu informieren und jeder hat das Recht zu publizieren.
Wir haben ja in Deutschland ein Informationsfreiheitsgesetz, wofür auch der CCC gekämpft hat und was so eine totale Totgeburt ist, weil sie da Schranken eingebaut haben, um zu verhindern, dass die Leute jetzt alle loslaufen und einen Zugriff auf die Dokumente kriegen.
Also das wichtigste Problem ist, dass die an Deutschland Informationsfreiheitsgesetz ist, dass da die Regel durchgekommen ist und auch gerichtlich bestätigt ist, dass die im Gesetz so gültig ist, das ist immerhin dieses Gesetz mal Angriff vom Verfassungsgericht, dass Unternehmen ein Recht darauf haben, ihre Daten geheim zu halten. Auch in dem Sinne, dass Verträge zum Beispiel, die zwischen öffentlicher Hand und Firm gemacht werden, geheim gehalten werden, weil da Firmengeheimnisse drinstehen können. Und dass diese Firmengeheimnisse das Recht der Öffentlichkeit auf Informationen überwiegen. Also der Geburtsfehler an dem deutschen Informationsfreiheitsgesetz. Und der zweite Fehler ist natürlich, dass die Fristen und die Kosten, die da festgesetzt sind, für das Herausgeben von Informationen extrem lang sind. Und dass die Behörden nicht dazu angehalten sind, Daten prinzipiell informationsfreiheitsgesetzfreundlich zu halten. In dem Sinne, dass eben möglichst keine Vermischung mit personenbezogene Daten stattfinden soll bei solchen Sachen. Sodass halt man diese Daten auch einfach mal relativ entspannt und sportlich releasen kann, ohne dass da immer noch ein großes Problem entsteht.
Das ist halt auch nicht das Ziel der Datenhaltung in Behörden.
Nee, aber es sollte es halt sein, weil ich meine, Gott, die sind uns rechtsstaatspflichtig. Die sind halt irgendwie die, die wir bezahlen.
Ja, das sehen die aber anders.
Ich weiß, dass sie das anders sehen. Aber naja, aber jedenfalls diese Idee halt zu sagen, es gibt Informationsfreiheit und darum geht's, steht ja auch dahinter zu sagen, lass uns Memorals von Wikileaks machen, also lass uns halt möglichst viele Spiegelserver anlegen, auf denen, also jetzt nicht Spiegel das Magazin, sondern Spiegelungen des Inhalts von Wikileaks, um sicherzustellen, dass die Daten halt nie wieder aus dem Netz entfernt werden können. Und wenn man sich so anguckt, was jetzt so mögliche Bedrohungssonarien sind, dann erwarte ich schon noch, dass die Amis noch mal zumindest einen helldischen Versuch unternehmen, Wikileaks platz zu machen, also halt auf jeden zu verhindern, dass da mehr Sachen publiziert werden und dergleichen Dinge mehr.
Also wenn man sich ansieht, was sie bisher gemacht haben, nämlich den Geldfluss angreifen, das ist so eins zu eins aus dem Anti-Terror-Manual, was sie haben. Also das ist so, wie die gerade vorgehen. Die haben da keine Wikileaks-Strategie, sondern die machen einfach, was sie immer machen, wenn sie glauben, es handelt sich um... Also die Idee, dass ein Idealist kommt und gegen die USA kämpfen könnte, ist völlig abwegig für die, sodass da jemand kommt, der irgendwie kein Geld braucht, um das zu tun, was er tut. So, darauf kommen die einfach nicht, dass Leute freiwillig irgendwie... Auch, dass es Spenden sind, das haben die, glaube ich, nicht realisiert. Das ist einfach Leute, die die Idee gut finden, da Geld hingeben. So, das ist denen, glaube ich, völlig fremd. Also, ich wollte noch mal ein bisschen ausführen, der CCC macht das ja auch, dass wir Grundrechte implementieren, von denen wir glauben, dass die Bürger darauf zugefahren sollen. Also wir haben zum Beispiel als CCC einen Jabba-Server in Betrieb, der auch Krypto supportet und da kann man also verschlüsselt mit anderen Leuten kommunizieren und sich sicher sein, dass da halt keiner abhört auf dem Weg. Natürlich muss man uns trauen an der Stelle, aber es gibt auf Jabba-Aufbau noch Ende-zu-Ende-Verschlüsselungssysteme, deren Nutzen wir auch empfehlen. Genau, das sollte die auf jeden Fall tun. Aber wir sehen es schon als Club, als unsere Pflicht an, auch Grundrechte durch technische Implementierung voranzutreiben. Und wir haben auch bei Tor zum Beispiel Infrastruktur, die wir da haben. Und es gab auch mal Crypto-Wars. Die Regierung in Deutschland hat ja mal versucht, Cryptografie generell.
Die Regierung in Deutschland war da mehr oder minder nur ein Randspieler. Also die ersten Crypto-Wars gingen darum, dass die amerikanische Regierung den sogenannten Clipper-Chip in alle Verschlüsselungsprodukte einbauen wollte. Die Idee dahinter ist folgende. Man sagt, klar, die Industrie braucht Verschlüsselungen, um sich gegen die bösen Chinesen zu sichern. Oder wen auch immer.
Die bösen Russen damals?
Die Russen damals. Vor etwa 92, da waren die Russen gerade schon so vorbei. Aber die Chinesen gingen los. Jedenfalls, man muss seine Geheimnisse sichern. Aber dann kann die Regierung nicht mehr mitlesen. Also bauen wir da was ein, was unter dem Namen Key Escrow bekannt wurde. Da ging es halt darum zu sagen, es gibt eine stabilisierte, regierungsamtlich abgesehenen Verschlüsselungstechnologie, die an sich erstmal sicher ist. Also wo man sich einigermaßen sicher sein kann, dass der Gegner sie nicht brechen kann. Aber jeder Schlüssel, der da verwendet wird, wird parallel dazu mit einem Regierungsschlüssel verschlüsselt, sodass die Regierung Zugang auf diesen Schlüssel nehmen kann. Und dann gab es eine Implementierung davon, das war dann so ein Clipper-Chip. Den hat die NSA zusammen mit AT&T entwickelt damals. Da gab es auch eine Implementierung unseres Telefons, also des Desktop-Telefons, ein verschlüsseltes Desktop-Telefon, wo dieser Clipper-Chip drin war. Da gab es eine Festplattenverschlüsselungseinheit und damals ein Modem-Encrypter, also um die Datenverbindung, also einmal alles, was man so braucht. So war die Idee dabei.
Wobei das Krypto-Verfahren ist ja auch relativ schnell gebrochen worden damals, wenn ich mich recht entspreche.
Ja, das Krypto-Verfahren, das Skip-Check war halt nichts. Da gab es dann offensichtlich den Bedarf der NSA, noch sicherzustellen, dass selbst wenn jemand den Key nicht rausrückt, sie immer noch zugreifen können.
Nur weil die Russen das nicht lesen können, da ist es ja nicht, dass wir es nicht auch lesen können. Genau, selbst wenn du die Platte abbrauchst.
Was dann halt passiert war, da gab es längere gesetzgeberische Auseinandersetzungen um dieses Ding und gewonnen wurden die Crypto-Wars von uns, kann man sagen. Zumindest einige Leute hier aus dem Umfeld. Und ich auch, war damals sehr intensiv beteiligt. Und da nahm auch Jock Taus, der war damals sehr wichtig beim Gewinnen der Crypto-Wars in Deutschland. Und die Strategie war halt eine zweigeteilte. Die eine war halt, erstmal die Debatten hinzuziehen. Also dafür zu sorgen, dass es halt nicht schnell geht, sondern dass es halt eine mögliche Einwendung gibt von Seiten Industrie und von Seiten von allen Mögen, von menschenrechtsorganisationen und dergleichen Dingen.
Die Industrie fand es ja auch von sich aus nicht so toll.
Nee, die Industrie fand es scheiße, weil sie hätten halt irgendwie zertifizierte Verfahren verwenden müssen, die der Staat zu Griff hat. Und Herr Gott, die wollen halt auch ihre Steuern hinterziehen. So, und, also halt dafür zu sorgen... Nein, diesen Teil hier können wir kurz... Also die wollen halt auch ihre Geheimnisse bewahren. So, und der zweite Teil war halt einfach, Technologie zu deployen. Also halt einfach im großen Umfang dafür zu sorgen, dass OpenSSL verwendet wird, dass TLS verwendet wird, dass wir PGP überall ausgerollt kriegen. Also einfach dafür zu sorgen, dass sie nicht mehr in der Lage sind, Kropotographie zu verbieten. Damals gab es ja noch diese Geschichten, dass PGP exportkontrolliert war. Ich meine, da mögen sich noch wenige Leute daran erinnern. PGP, was heute ein rein kommerzielles Produkt ist, damals von Phil Zimmermann geschrieben. Das erste halbwegs benutzbare E-Mail-Verschlüsselprogramm. Also halbwegs benutzbar. Und das konnte halt aus den USA nicht exportiert werden. Und der Trick, der also jedenfalls nicht offiziell, natürlich gab es auch schon Netze, trotzdem exportiert.
Es ist in Buchform.
Genau. Es wurde halt ausgedruckt und abgetippt, beziehungsweise eingescannt, um halt wieder dafür zu sein.
Ja, es war tatsächlich ein Buch, so aufgebunden. Also die Idee war, als Buch durfte man es exportieren und dann haben wir hier noch auf welchem Camp war das?
Free Speech war es ja dann in dem Fall.
Welches Camp war denn das nochmal, wo wir das hier dann...
Das ist das erste, glaube ich, gewesen.
Es kam noch so eine Aktion in Holland, wo wir dann diesen Scheiß abgetippt haben, die PGP-Sourcen. So Rückblicken natürlich total hanebüchen, ist ja nicht so, als wenn wir nicht auch Krypto irgendwie Leute gehabt hätten. Aber naja.
Ja, da ging es halt aber auch eben darum, anzusagen, dass halt diese Krypto-Exportregulierung halt irgendwie in der Form, wie sie damals unterwegs waren, völlig Banane waren. Also jedenfalls, die ersten Kryptowars wurden halt gewonnen durch eine Kombination aus Zähigkeit und Technologie-Deployment. Und was wir jetzt aber sehen, was jetzt wieder losgeht in den USA, ist ja, dass das FBI hingeht und sagt, sie wollen wieder Zugriff auf alle Formen von verschlüsselter Kommunikation haben. Also sie wollen halt mit genau demselben Ding, mit dem sie gerade Paypal und Mastercard und Visa und Amazon dazu gezwungen haben, ihnen zu willen zu sein, wollen sie jetzt alle anderen Firmen auch dazu zwingen, sagen halt, du kannst nur noch Business in Amiland machen, wenn du uns auf Anfrage-Clear-Text gibst. So und ich bin mal gespannt, wie die amerikanischen Technologieunternehmen darauf reagieren. Weil, also ich wüsste, was ich tun würde, wenn ich ein Technologieunternehmen in Amiland wäre und mit so weit konfrontiert würde, dann würde ich sagen, gab's doch einen schönen Tag noch, jetzt hab ich meine Steuern woanders.
Dann machen sie das sowieso. Die haben doch eh alle irgendwie, Hauptquartier ist doch in Bambuda und so und so. Dann machst du da halt auch deine...
So, ich meine, deshalb... Dann hast du halt in Kalifornien halt noch irgendwie ein Büro für die Ansichtskarten oder so.
Also übrigens ist das ja auch so, dass wenn man jetzt hier zu Google geht, also das heißt ja einmal amerikanische Firma, amerikanische Gesetze, aber wenn ihr zu Google geht und macht mal irgendwie einen Trace-Route oder so, das steht in Deutschland, die Server. Also es ist nicht so, dass...
Also die...
Ja, also wenn ihr aus Deutschland zu Google geht, dann kommt ihr bei einem deutschen Rechenzentrum raus, was von durch Google gehört, aber selbstverständlich sind die mit ihren deutschen Rechenzentren an deutsche Gesetze gebunden. Ja, so ist das nicht. Also so leicht kommt man da nicht raus. Und das heißt eben, also selbst wenn jetzt hier wieder eine Neuauflage der Cryptowars kommt, wo wir natürlich auch gegen kämpfen werden, ja. Und die Versuche gab es auch in Deutschland, weil ich mich nur an Frankreich erinnere. Da gab es ja auch lange Zeit ein komplettes Kryptoverbot, außer so ganz schmal brüstige, die irgendwie jeder zu Hause bei sich hätte berechnen können. Und in Russland ist es heute noch problematisch, Kryptografie einzusetzen. Also so weit entfernt ist das leider nicht. Ja, also die Zivilisationsdecke ist dünn, sage ich da.
Ja, also und dazu kommen jetzt natürlich noch andere Mechanismen. Also wir haben jetzt überall bei den Internet-Service-Providern stehen halt DPI-Systeme. Und also die Packet-Inspection-Systeme, mit denen man halt in alle Pakete reingucken kann und mit denen man auch in der Lage wäre, so wie Wikileaks halt irgendwie zu blockieren. Das würde technisch schon funktionieren. Also worauf es jetzt halt ankommt, ist eben dafür zu sorgen, dass das nicht passiert. Also dass halt einfach die Internet-Service-Provider sich auf ihre Rolle als hier stehen Server am Rack und wir schieben Bits, versteifen und sagen, für alles andere sind wir einfach nicht zuständig. Nicht unsere Aufgabe. Wollen wir auch nicht. Und wenn das nicht passiert, dann sind wir ein Diebschitt. Und das ist halt so ein Problem, dessen sich viele Leute momentan noch nicht bewusst sind. Dass die Zivilisationsdecke dünn ist. Also es ist nicht so, dass es selbstverständlich ist, dass es einen freien Internet da draußen gibt, in dem Zensur sehr schwierig ist.
Und in dem du frei verschlüsseln kannst, mit wem du willst. Also übrigens eine Ansage, die wir sonst auch gerne tun und die ich auch an der Stelle nochmal tun will, lieber mehr als weniger verschlüsseln. Wenn ihr nie verschlüsselt, außer die eine Mail an den einen Wikileaks-Kontakt, dann ist der Regierung völlig klar, was da drin steht. Aber wenn ihr immer alles verschlüsselt, dann ist der Anscheinensbeweis eben nicht gegeben, dass ihr da was geleakt habt. Dann kann das auch einfach ein Hallo, wie ist da jemand sein? Insofern lieber alles verschlüsseln und dann ist völlig klar, als irgendwie nur bei Bedarf irgendwas. Gewöhnt euch das über direkt an, immer schön verschlüsseln. Je mehr, desto besser.
Ja, auch eure Fistplatten und eure Chats und alles.
Insbesondere die Chats.
Insbesondere die Chats, ja. Und auch die Chat-Logs, wenn es geht.
Na, gar nicht erst loggen.
Oder gar nicht erst loggen.
Das ist nur Daten, die nicht da sind, können auch nicht missbraucht werden.
Ja. Na jedenfalls, das ist eben denke ich mal der Grund, warum so viele Leute diesen Kampf um Wikileaks jetzt als so bedeutsam ansehen, weil sie halt einfach schon zu Recht das Gefühl haben, dass es jetzt so eine gewisse Entscheidungsschlacht um die freie Meinungsäußerung im Internet ist. Und jetzt glaube ich, die Leute die sagen, ja, es ist ja keine Meinungsäußerung, weil es sind ja nur die Passion, aber es ist Bullshit. So hier geht es einfach darum, um das Recht, Informationen zu verbreiten, das Recht, Informationen entgegenzunehmen. Und das sind halt grundlegende Menschenrechte, die verteidigt gehören. Und deswegen ist es eben auch wichtig, irgendwie Mirrors von Wikileaks anzulegen, selbst wenn man irgendwie Probleme mit der Person von Julian oder wem auch immer hat. Die Idee, die dahinter steht, ist eben, dass Regierungen transparent sein müssen. Und wenn wir nicht in der Lage sind, dafür zu sorgen, dass die Informationen, die dazu notwendig sind, weiter verbreitet werden können, dann werden Regierungen auch einfach nicht transparent sein. Dann werden die halt immer schlimmer werden. Und dann wird es da auch überhaupt keine Möglichkeit geben, die Dinge irgendwie zum besseren zu wenden.
Also die werden auch so immer schlimmer werden, aber wir werden es immerhin sehen.
Ja, oder vielleicht wird es auch ein bisschen langsamer. Wenn Julian's Theorie zutrifft, dass die halt einfach, wenn genügend geleakt wird, nicht mehr in der Lage sind, so effektiv Scheiße zu bauen, denn...
Das weiß ich sehr hoffbar im Übrigen...
.dann tritt vielleicht wirklich dieser Belgien-Effekt ein global.
Ich finde das super. Bei uns, weißt du, wenn wir alles zurückrollen würden, was die Regierung in dieser Legislaturperiode gemacht hätten, da wäre, glaube ich, nichts irgendwie schlechter.
Na die interessante Frage ist halt...
Ich meine, teilweise haben sie es ja schon selber zurückgerollt, diese Hotelierszahlen. Naja, also man darf es nicht unterschätzen. Die Leute, also wir haben ja gesagt, es gibt diese Strategie der Regierung, dass man das Netz so weit zu macht, wie es geht und dass man sich auf dem Tag vorbereitet, wo man gegen das Volk arbeitet und nicht mehr als Regierung des Volkes. Da gibt es Notstandsgesetze, es gibt diese ganze Sicherheitsscheiße. Das ist alles eine Vorbereitung darauf, dass eines Tages eben hier der Euro platzt und dass die Leute eine Hyperinflation kriegen und nichts mehr für ihr Geld kaufen können. Und an der Stelle will die Regierung vorgesorgt haben und da gehört eben auch dazu, dass es dann kein freies Internet mehr gibt. Und bisher haben sie es versucht mit so was wie Kinderpornografie oder mit offensichtlich verbotenen Sachen und die gibt es leider gar nicht so viel im Internet. Dann haben sie eben die Raubkopien genommen. Aber das sind alles Versuche im Grunde dafür zu sorgen, ein Regularium im Internet einzuführen, mit dem die Regierung dann Sachen zumachen kann.
Also der Punkt ist halt, dass ab jetzt muss sich jeder Gesetzesvorschlag, der da kommt, der irgendwie Informationsregulierung im Internet einführen will, den Vorwurf gefallen lassen, dass es ein Lex-Wikileaks ist.
Das ist gut so. Vielen Dank, Julian.
Ja, genau. Das kann man nicht alle sagen. Ich habe da noch so einen Punkt zu deiner Belgien-Theorie.
Lass hören.
Naja, also das Problem daran ist, dass es schon so ist, dass zumindest bestimmte Funktionen der Regierung, jetzt nicht unbedingt der politischen, aber zumindest des Apparats, zwingend notwendig sind, um halt hier nicht in dem Wildwest von Konzernen entstehen zu lassen. Also ich meine sowas wie Kartellbehörden, die dann ja doch manchmal was tun.
Na die Behörden laufen ja alle weiter. Es ist nur so, dass es keine Regierung gibt. Es gibt keine neuen Gesetze.
Du meinst also keine politische Regierung?
Genau, es gibt keine neuen Gesetze mehr. Das heißt, die ganzen alten Gesetze, die sind zwar vielleicht auch teilweise nicht toll, aber sie sind also nicht so objektiv scheiße wie die neuen Gesetze. Das wird ja alles nur immer schlimmer. Und der Teil fällt halt weg. Es wird einfach nicht mehr schlimmer. Wir haben zumindest die zuverlässige Situation, dass es nicht schlimmer wird.
Okay, also sowas ähnliches wie Stabilität. Nun sagen natürlich die Politiker, dass es zwingend notwendig ist, dass man reagiert. Also dass halt einfach Neuentwicklungen, dass man die halt irgendwie eindämmt.
Ja, wie zum Beispiel das Internet.
Genau, so was wie das Internet.
Und Kryptografie, da muss man drauf reagieren, indem man es verbietet.
Ja, also wir gehen mal davon aus, dass in einem Belgien-Zustand zumindest irgendwie die wesentlichen notwendigen Sachen noch getan werden. Also insbesondere halt, was irgendwie Umweltschutz und Eindämmung von Kanzlerkonzernen und Verbraucherschutz und dergleichen Dinge mehr betrifft und Sozialwesen.
Die haben übrigens einen lustigen Verbraucherschutz in Belgien. Das passt hier gar nicht rein, aber ich will es trotzdem mal erwähnt haben. Die haben ein Anti-Bundling-Gesetz. Das heißt, du darfst zum Beispiel kein Mobiltelefon verkaufen, was an ein Netz gebunden ist. Das steht einfach im Gesetz drin. Das heißt, das iPhone zum Beispiel gab es da sofort für alle Netze. Das kostet dann entsprechend mehr, aber es gibt halt kein Bandlink.
Okay.
Also, ich meine, da kann man sich durchaus mal orientieren dran. Hätte man auch sagen können, das wäre mal eine Sache gewesen, wo ich gesagt hätte, wir hören immer EU-Harmonisierung, Verbraucherschutz. Das könnte man doch mal harmonisieren. Machen wir das doch mal. Weißt du, das wäre mal ein Vorschlag, der in eine positive Richtung geht. Aber bisher ist doch alle Harmonisierung im Grunde gegen uns gelaufen.
Na ja, es gab ein paar Ausnahmen, die gibt es schon. Man muss noch ein bisschen gucken. Aber zum Beispiel halt die...
Mir fällt ja keiner hin.
Na ja, also zum Beispiel so Sachen wie halt irgendwie die Harmonisierung in der EU, Geldtransfers ist schon okay. Das macht schon... Das finde ich schon...
Geldwäsche Gesetze, die wir...
Nee, nicht die Geldwäsche Gesetze, sondern...
Was denn, die kommen doch daher oder nicht?
Nee, dass es in der EU Überweisungen gibt, die sie nicht mehr in den Arm und Bein kosten können, finde ich schon ganz okay. Und irgendwie, dass es halt...
Wasserdrom, hier mal für uns getan...
Genau, das ist doch das Gesundheitses-Thema.
Aqueduct, na gut.
Also ja, das ist halt so eine Wasserdrom, die für uns getan ist. Da können wir glaube ich abkürzen. Worüber wir auf jeden Fall noch reden müssen, ist die...
Der Cyberwar.
Der Cyberwar, der sogenannte, der da draußen stattfinden soll. Also was da draußen passiert, aus meiner Sicht, ist halt irgendwie kein Cyberwar. Das ist halt irgendwie so, ja, so Knappenschlägereien im Netz halt. Irgendwie anders kann man das eigentlich nicht nennen. Das ist kein Cyberwar. Und wenn da mal halt irgendwie Paypal irgendwie für ein paar Stunden kein Geld transferieren kann, dann ist das vielleicht auch irgendwie... Na ja, davon geht die Welt halt nicht unter, so ehrlich.
Ist ja auch nicht deren Kernaufgabe, Geld zu transferieren, oder? War jedenfalls nicht mein Eindruck bei denen, sondern es geht ja darum, mein Geld zu ihnen zu transferieren und nicht irgendwie Geld zu mir zu transferieren.
Es geht schon um Geldtransfer, es geht nur ohne Spezifikation in der Richtung. Genau. Also die ist für die schon sehr klar. Mir kommt es ein bisschen so vor, als hieß es ja ja, die wilden Horden, die DDoSer, also der Distributed Denial-of-Service-Angreifer, gehen da gegen die armen Internetfirmen vor. Aber wenn man sich den anguckt, da gibt es keine Strukturen, sondern dieses Anonymous, was aus einem Laden namens Fortune hervorgegangen ist. Das ist also ein Bilderboard, das muss man sagen. Also ein Board, wo man noch ihr Bildchen posten kann und dazu Kommentare abgeben kann. Und wo sich halt ein extrem eigenes, sehr geschlossenes Soziotop entwickelt hat mit einem äußerst eigenen schrägen Humor.
Also sie haben das Alleinstellungsmerkmal, oder ja, Alleinstellung auch nicht mehr, aber das Merkmal von Fortune ist, ist, dass die Sachen von sich aus verschwinden. Das heißt, es gibt da keinen Paper Trail.
Kein Archiv.
Es gibt kein Archiv. Was gestern gepostet ist, ist weg.
Es ist halt keine Publikation.
Und das heißt eben auch, dass man da im Grunde, wenn man da was als Anonymous postet, nicht sich sorgen machen muss, dass irgendwie die Polizei, wenn sie da eine Woche später kommt und das haben will, da noch irgendwas findet, weil da ist halt nichts mehr. Das hat eben dazu gesorgt, dass die Leute sich da eben auch sammeln, die gerne irgendwie an der Polizei vorbei irgendwie Sachen ber reden wollen. Also das ist durchaus, zieht das dann eben die Leute an, die auch gerne anonym rumtrollen.
Also ich vergleiche das halt immer mit so einer Kneipe. Also das ist halt so eine Kneipe, wo du Bar zahlst. Ja, in einer Kneipe, wo du Bar zahlst und da wo du dich halt unter einem Kneipen-Tisch unterhältst, und das ist halt laut und niemand anderes kann hören, was du sagst. Oder außer die Leute, die an dem selben Tisch sitzen.
Und wenn sich ein Mord bildet.
Am nächsten morgen ist das halt vergessen, weil alle so besoffen waren.
Das ist eine gute Analogie.
Die Sache, die jetzt passiert ist, ist, dass in den 20er- und Anfang der 30er-Jahre in den Kneipen Putz gemacht wurde. Da bist du halt hingegangen, wenn du schlechte Laune hattest, dass du Rundabbau hattest, durch Leute aufs Maul hauen. Und dann hat die gesagt, ey, lass mal den Launer platt machen. Dann sind die Leute halt losgezogen und haben den platt gemacht. Und je für je nachher ist das jetzt auch so. Das ist halt nicht schön, aber weißt Gott kein Cyberwar. Da muss man halt einfach mal so ein bisschen die Verhältnismäßigkeit warnen. Es gab ja diesen Vergleich, dass Anonymos und Fortune der schwarze Block des Internets sei.
Was ich ein sehr schönes Bild finde, aber es trifft es halt nicht.
Gerade bei den Berliner Demonstrationen gibt es von der Polizei immer diesen schönen Begriff der erlebnisorientierten Jugendlichen. Das heißt, die, die halt an den Ecken stehen und drauf warten, dass irgendwas passiert und dann halt...
Die zu Demos gehen. So, eigentlich nicht mit dem erklärten Ziel, da Flaschen zu werfen, aber...
Die sind dann meistens auch nicht bei den Demos, sondern danach da. Also wenn halt irgendwie die Demo schon vorbei ist.
Also wenn überall die Scherben liegen, um zu gucken, ob man da irgendwie was sehen kann.
Ob noch irgendwas passiert, also ob noch irgendwie sozusagen noch ein bisschen rennen und schmeißen gibt. Und so ähnlich kommt mir diese Anonymos-Fortune-Geschichte ja halt auch vor. Interessant ist eigentlich, dass es da durchaus Leute gibt, die halt einen sehr viel höheren politischen Anspruch haben und sagen, naja, so was wir hier tun, hat halt schon Hand und Fuß. Und das ist halt ein Online-, also der Ausdruck eines Online-Protests. Also in dem Sinne, also auch noch so ein Vergleich, wie da so eine von den vielen nicht zutreffenden oder teilweise zumindest zutreffenden Analogien ist halt eine Sitzblockade. Na, es ist halt so, als wenn man halt da hingeht vor so die Konzernzentrale und halt die blockiert und sich da 2000 Leute davor setzen, dann ist die halt dicht, dann kannst du da halt auch kein Business mehr machen. Und so ähnlich ist es halt auch. Und wenn die Leute halt wieder weggehen, dann ist es halt auch wieder weg. Und der Unterschied halt zu sonstigen DDoS-Angriffen ist halt, dass die in der Regel halt mit so einem Botnetzen geführt werden. Das heißt also, da werden Rechner, die ja aufgemacht wurden, automatisch meistens und infiziert wurden, ferngesteuert, um Server platt zu machen. Das ist so in der Online-Gaming-Branche, so Poker und so, ist es wohl ziemlich üblich, dass die sich gegenseitig die Server wegschießen. Teilweise auch in der Porn-Branche. Es ist halt so ein halb kriminelles Gewerbe, aber das ist in diesem Fall nicht der Fall.
Das ist nicht, was 4chan macht.
Genau, was 4chan macht. Es ist eine Sitzblockade.
Die haben so eine Art Applet, also das ist schon auch semi-automatisiert. Die haben irgendwie so eine Art kleines Applet, was du halt starten kannst auf deinem Windows-Rechner. Und der holt sich dann entweder, kannst du manuell das Ziel einstellen oder er holt sich das aus dem IRC-Channel. Und da holt er sich dann die IP und den Port, welchen Dienst er da angreifen soll, und schickt dann da halt Traffic hin. Also das ist schon... Das ist kein Botnet, weil man beim Botnet erkennst du ja normalerweise nicht, dass du gerade gehyjagt wurdest. Sondern hier ist es, dass du explizit auf deinem Rechner klickst, um dieses Tool zu starten. Das heißt irgendwie, wie hieß es? Das ist die Lobitale Ionen-Kanone.
Ich weiß es, die Low Earth Orbit-Ionen-Kanone. Super, naja. Der Unterschied ist eben schon gegeben.
Es gibt sogar eine JavaScript-Version davon jetzt.
Wie geil. Dass es eben ein bewusster Ausdruck von Protest ist, in dem Sinne, dass man sich bewusst ist, was man da tut. Und eben nicht nur eine Million gehaltereckte Rechner benutzt, um was anderes plattzumachen. Insofern ist das schon ein wichtiger Unterschied. Ich will es auch nicht pauschal verdammen. Es ist einfach so, dass es eine Form des Protests ist, die wir per se nicht besonders gut heißen. Insbesondere, wenn es sich nicht gegen Zahlungssysteme, sondern gegen Webseiten oder Twitter oder was auch immer richtet, dann dient es auch dazu, Kommunikation zu unterbinden. Das ist per se eine schlechte Sache. Wenn wir eine Chance haben, diese Welt noch ins Lot zu kriegen, dann gehört Kommunikation ganz sicher dazu. Kommunikation zu unterbinden, ist halt scheiße. Das ist immer scheiße. Deswegen sind wir im Club uns einig, dass Serviceangriffe nicht zum Repertoire politischen Handelns im Netz gehören sollten. Auf der anderen Seite ist es so, dass es offensichtlich eine ganze Generation von Leuten gibt, die das als Mittel ihres legitimen Protestausdrucks empfinden.
Und die auch wütend genug sind, um anderen Leuten die Infrastruktur kaputt machen zu wollen. Was ich eigentlich eine starke Aussage finde. Also ich bin ja auch häufig wütend auf Leute und Institutionen, aber wütend genug, um dahin zu gehen, irgendwie mit dem Vorschlaghammer und die Sachen klein zu klappen, das ist ja schon nochmal ein Schritt. Insofern finde ich das schon aus dem Gesichtspunkt sehr interessant zu sagen. So viel Wut ist doch da. Also naja.
Das zeigt eben auch das Level der Eskalation, was da erreicht ist. Also dass einfach der Angriff auf etwas, was als möglicher Ausweg aus diesem ganzen Schlamassel empfunden wurde, nämlich Wikileaks, dann so gravierend empfunden wird, dass man halt etwas sagt, so ey, das reicht jetzt aber. Und jetzt tun wir uns halt zusammen und sorgen mal dafür, dass die Firmen, die da daran schuld sind, halt auch darunter zu leiden haben, ist halt schon mal merkenswert. Also wir gehen halt einen anderen Weg. Also die Holland-Stiftung hat halt sich in einen relativ bissigen Anwalt genommen, um halt die Paper zur Resson zu bringen.
Das tut glaub ich noch mehr, wie er jetzt so ein DDoS-System hat.
Ja, das ist halt, ich mein, das ist vielleicht doch einfach wirklich eine Frage von Alter und Sozialisierung oder wie auch immer. Aber wie gesagt, ich will halt deswegen nicht sagen, dass das scheiße ist oder so. Es ist halt nur, also was wir halt doof finden, ist halt DDoS gegen Kommunikationssysteme. Also Systeme, die halt einfach für Kommunikation da sind, platt zu machen, geht halt mal überhaupt gar nicht, egal unter welchen Umständen. So auch wenn jemand sie benutzt, der den man nicht mag, es geht jetzt nicht, ja, halt Kommunikation platt zu machen, weil dann kann man einfach nicht miteinander reden, so. Die, das haben wir damals halt auch gesagt, als wir, wir haben eine gemeinsame Erklärung rausgegeben mit verschiedenen anderen Hackergruppen zum, damals auch noch mit dem Call of the Dead Cow. Als es darum ging, da verschiedene, bzw. eine Hackergruppe hatte zum Cyberwar gegen China und Iran und dergleichen Dinge aufgerufen, so in den 90ern. Können wir auch nochmal verlinken.
Das musst du auch mal rausdruhen, das habe ich nie gesehen.
Warte mal, das suche ich gerade mal raus. Ja, such das mal nachher raus.
Also wir haben so einen ähnlichen Fall gehabt beim letzten Kongress, da sind irgendwelche Nazi-Foren gehackt worden, oder aber das ist der Vorletzte. Und da stellt sich ja auch die Frage, das ist letztendlich ein Angriff auf Kommunikationsstrukturen. Und so wenig wir die Leute mögen, die da abhängen, so sehr finden wir doch, dass jeder ein Grundrecht auf Kommunikation haben sollte.
Also damals ging es, also im Januar 99, da haben wir zusammen mit 2600, dem Call of the Dead Cow, HispaHack, Loft, Frack und den portugiesischen Hackern ein Statement rausgebracht. Da ging es um eine Gruppe namens Legion of the Undergrounds, die haben eine Declaration of War gegen die Regierung von Irak und China rausgebracht und wollten halt alle Hacker aufrufen, sich dagegen zu wenden. Und da haben wir halt einfach auch den Klage gesagt, es geht halt überhaupt nicht, da halt einfach irgendwie jetzt irgendwie Cyber Wars auszurufen und sich da halt zum Lakaien von einer Regierung zu machen. Insofern überlegt euch gut, was er tut so. Wie gesagt, mag halt eine legitime Protestform sein, aber was halt auf gar keinen Fall geht, das ist halt Infrastruktur platt machen, die halt der Kommunikation und Information dient. Da ist auch für uns auf jeden Fall die Grenze des moralisch Vertretbaren erreicht von rechtlich reden, mal hier gerade mal hier gar nicht.
Also auch aus rechtlichen Gründen rufen wir keinesfalls dazu auf, dass ihr jetzt irgendjemand angreift, im Gegenteil.
Genau, also eine wesentlich konstruktivere Methode Wikileaks zu unterstützen, ist in jedem Fall, Mühe raus aufzusetzen, also einfach...
Wobei da gibt es auch genug, gibt es jetzt irgendwie über 400 oder was las ich da?
Das sind jetzt über 1000, aber...
Also das ist auch eher ein Polithack, wo ich auch wieder sagen muss, Hut ab, Julien, das war nicht so, dass es da wirklich Mühe raus bedroht hätte. Es gab auch schon vorher genug, aber das war so ein Hack, um die Leute dazu zu bringen, dass sie ihre Solidarität zeigen und das haben sie getan.
Nee, ich denke, das hat tatsächlich auch einen technischen Hintergrund, es muss halt Tausende geben davon, nicht bloß ein paar Dutzend, weil ein paar Dutzend kannst du technisch platt machen und ein paar Tausend kannst du nicht mehr technisch platt machen. Deswegen macht Mühe raus. Wir brauchen mehr davon, es ist nicht so, dass wir genug Mühe haben.
Naja, was heißt brauchen, also man hätte auch warten können, bis irgendwie die zwölf runter sind.
Der Punkt ist, dass die Technologie, um eine Handvoll Mörers platt zu machen, ist da. Die funktioniert und die wird auch eingesetzt. Deswegen muss es von Anfang an Tausende Mörers geben, damit überhaupt niemand auf die Idee kommt, es zu versuchen.
Na du hättest auch erstmal dich Dossen lassen können und dann mehr Mörer sein können.
Nein, kannst du nicht, weil dann kriegst du z.B. möglicherweise die Informationen nicht mehr raus.
Na, die kannst du ja vorher verteilen, der Mörer muss ja nicht online sein.
Aber anyway, hört auf mit solchen durch die Hintertür Gedanken, es geht darum, macht Mörers. Macht einfach Mörers, das ist ein konstruktiver Weg, um sicherzustellen, dass die Informationen nicht verschwinden und vor allen Dingen macht auch Mörers von den alten Wikileaks-Contents, weil die sind momentan halt eben zum Teil nicht mehr zugreifbar, weil die halt eben auf Servern liegen, die eben jetzt gerade weg sind. Und die es halt eben keinen Zugriff mehr gibt, weil die eben plattgemacht wurden. Es wird halt nur der Content gemürert, der gerade aktuell ist und das ist halt scheiße.
Ich sag mal voraus, dass man auf dem Kongress und irgendwelchen FDP-Servern Backups ziehen kann oder in Torrens. Und das solltet ihr tun, schon für den Privatgebrauch. Und wie groß das Risiko ist, so ein Mörer aufzusetzen in Deutschland, das ist unklar.
Also es ist halt die ISPs, sagen halt mittlerweile.
Es gibt da so eine Liste von ISPs. Aus Sicht des ISPs ist das keine gute Frage. Denn wenn du sie vorher fragst, dann setzt du sie in Kenntnis davon, dass du vorhast, diese Inhalte zu hosten. Und damit sind sie dann laut Telemedien-Gesetz oder das heißt in Zugzwang. Also lieber nicht fragen, sondern einfach aufsetzen. Also strafrechtlich kann man da, das glaube ich im Moment, der Konzerts nicht viel gegen tun, gegen Wikileaks mehr oder weniger.
Es könnte halt sein, dass ihr euer Recht auf Einreise in die USA verwirkt, aber da will man momentan ja sowieso gerade nicht so richtig hin.
Na ja, außer manche Leute haben keine Wahl.
Gut, also denke mal, dass der Weg halt eben dafür zu sagen, dass die Informationen nie wieder aus dem Netz verschwinden können, ist der richtige so. Und die eben gerade die alten Daten, die halt eben momentan nicht bequem online sind, dass die halt auf vielen Möhren liegen und dass die halt wieder verfügbar sind, das ist ganz wichtig so, weil da sind halt echte Goldstücke dabei, soll die halt jetzt so ein bisschen an diesem ganzen Depeschen-Ding untergehen.
Apropos untergehen, da wollten wir auch noch drauf hin.
Stimmt, untergehen wollten wir auch noch reden.
Das ist eine Sache, die man immer wieder beobachten kann. Wenn so was wie Wikileaks jetzt gerade passiert und die Presse dominiert, das ist der Zeitpunkt, bei dem die alle ihren Klärschlamm im Ozean verklappen. Die ganzen Sachen, die sie schon immer machen wollten, und wo klar ist, dass die Presse darüber berichten wird, die macht man halt zu Zeitpunkten, wo man sich sicher sein kann, dass es in anderen Sachen untergeht, wie zum Beispiel den Problembär, oder wenn irgendwie überwetend das, irgendein Typ sich da verunfallt. Das sind so typische Sachen. Und Wikileaks eignet sich natürlich besonders gut gerade, weil das so eine längliche Aktion ist und über Wochen gehen soll. Und das ist die perfekte Zeit für Regierungen, Sachen zu machen, von denen sie nicht wollen, dass ihr die wahrnehmt. Selbst wenn sie nicht verhindern können, dass sie in der Presse auftauchen. Deswegen im Moment sorgfältig Presse lesen.
Ja, ganz wichtig auf die kleinen Meldungen achten, auf die Sachen achten, die halt nicht bei WPA kommen, sondern bei irgendwie, was weiß ich, 16 Uhr oder Ria Novosti oder ähnlichen von unseren Lieblingsdingern. Wo man halt einfach dann so die kleinen Meldungen sieht, was halt in irgendwelchen Ländern passiert, die halt überhaupt nicht so auf dem Radar sind. Und diese Strategie des sogenannten Burrowings, also des Verbuddelns von Leichen unter anderen großen News-Events, die ist in großem Maßstab zuerst von Clique von Tony Blair verwendet worden, die halt spezifisch halt Sachen schon vorbereitet hatten für den Zeitpunkt, wo irgendwas war. Also zum Beispiel bei dieser Diana-Geschichte, als Diana gestorben ist, da haben die endlos Kram drunter verbuddelt, wochenlang. So da haben die alles einmal so und zwar geht es halt darum, klar ausgemacht. Ja und es geht halt darum, dass es gibt halt so Sachen, die man also wo man damit rechnen muss, dass die öffentlich werden. So und dann ist es halt gut, wenn die zu einer Zeit öffentlich werden, wo niemand ihnen Aufmerksamkeit schenkt. Also wo man halt einfach dann nicht mehr sagen kann, ja wurde geheim gehalten. Ja, aber publiziert. Da gab es eine Presseerklärung.
Wie war das irgendwie die Planetarvernichtungsmeldung die jahrelang aus in Alpha Zetauri?
Genau. Wenn keiner darauf achtet, da können wir doch umfielen. Da können wir nur wirklich nichts für, da die nicht hingucken.
Traditionell macht man so was am Freitagabend. Die Amis machen zum Beispiel seit Jahren Releasen, die immer am Freitagabend, welche Banken denn diese Woche geplatzt sind.
Ja, wenn alle von nach Hause gehen.
Genau, da sind alle nach Hause gegangen. Am Wochenende haben die Leute eh, wollen sie keinen Bankenscheiß hören und am Montag ist es dann zu lange her, als dass es noch eine Story wäre. So macht man das.
Die Details zu dem neuen Plattform OpenLeaks werden wir in der nächsten oder übernächsten Sendung mit dem Daniel besprechen, der bis dahin hoffentlich dann online ist mit dieser Plattform, die dann sagte von sich, dass sie einige Sachen lernt, gelernt hat, aus dem, was sie bei Wikileaks falsch gemacht haben.
Das interessiert uns natürlich nicht.
Da sind wir sehr gespannt. Wir werden auch sicherlich in die technischen Aspekte ein bisschen tiefer einsteigen, für die Leute, die es interessiert, aber auch natürlich in die politischen und in die, ja, sagen wir mal, die Leak-taktischen Aspekte, die ja doch auch von großem Interesse sind für uns, um auch so ein bisschen zu hören, wie dann so die Erfahrungen waren und was irgendwie die Sachen sind, die schiefgegangen sind. Finden wir wesentlich interessanter als jetzt diese ganzen Geschichten da um Julian und seine rechtlichen Probleme. Insofern wünschen wir euch denn noch schöne Vor-, Winter-, Weihnachts-, was auch immer Zeit und verabschieden uns. Verabschieden wir uns bis zum nächsten Mal. Wenn ihr noch flatter Klicks überhabt, dann wisst ihr, wo sie lassen könnt. Wir versprechen euch, dass wir dafür schöne Bücher und komische Subscription-Services erwerben werden, die wir euch dann auch vorstellen bzw. die Informationen daraus.
Und ansonsten, dann holt euch ein Guardian-Abo.
Genau, wir sind aber auch verlinkt, wo es lang geht. Denn bis zum nächsten Mal.